[Music]
thank you
everybody's got to die but this cemetery
is full of people who have died in their
20s 30s 40s and 50s and every one of
them the dies of natural causes died of
nutritional deficiency disease this is a
blind spot for the medical profession
they don't get a single 30 seconds of
training and nutrition and as a result
ninety percent of the people in this
graveyard have died long before their
genetic potential of 120 and 140. you
know there's a revolution going on right
now some extraordinary individuals are
going to live to be 150 to 160. that
just sounds incredible are there are
there people that really live well oh
yes Health Care is controversial these
days maybe because at some point in our
lives we all need some generally when we
feel sick we run to the family doctor
for some pills a quick fix but one
doctor is touring Idaho trying to
convince us there's another way
if one looked at the differences between
a alternative or holistic practitioner
as opposed to what you might call a
straight or an orthodox practitioner you
might use five or six different things
to treat a patient you might use
acupuncture nutrition herbs and each one
of these sort of supplement each other
they enhance each other our dogs get 40
minerals our rats get 28 and our own
kids get 12 or less it's really a dog's
life it's these minerals it's a secret
glaciers grind up these rocks comes out
in form of glacial milk we're out here
surveying this wheat crop it looks
beautiful but looks are deceiving so you
can gained 20 years statistically simply
by not going to medical school
seventy percent of the medical doctors
who treat Medicare patients plunk the
exam
[Music]
cannot so it leaves you open to diseases
far far more horrible and arthritis than
in fact today I was in contact with the
oversight committee that actually called
me from the National Institutes of
Health the only way that you can get
certain minerals for instance selenium
and copper and zinc is to eat liver
three times a week Monday Wednesday
Friday and most Americans aren't going
to do that they just don't like it
everybody in the studio is sticking
their tongues out already the answer is
really not more taxes more Medicaid
Medicare the answer lies here with our
food
foreign
[Applause]
so I know who I'm talking to how many of
you are here tonight because you thought
this was a tax protest meeting
hey it's an election year it's going to
happen
and then let's see how many of you grew
up in a farm or had anything to do with
livestock sometime in your life okay
great we're gonna get along fine now the
reason why I asked that last question I
grew up on a bee farm myself about 80
miles west of St Louis like everybody
else that raises livestock you raise a
lot of your own feed to stay in business
economically and we raise corn and
soybeans and hay and we'd grind this
stuff up into a flower and we would add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
we'd make pellets and we'd feed those
calves for about six to nine months then
we'd ship them off to be butchered and
we'd save back the very best ones for
ourselves and you'd butcher them in the
barn now the thing that fascinated me as
a teenager was that we ate out of those
same Fields as a family we kept back
five rows of corn we had a garden at the
end of the field where we grew our peas
and beans and squash and tomatoes and
carrots and the part that fascinated me
was I was just ask my dad I'd say how
can we go to all that trouble for those
calves we grind up their feed we add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
make pellets feed them for six nine
months and we want to live to be a
hundred with no aches and pains we eat
out of the same fields and we don't give
ourselves the same vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals well he used to give
me a lot of Missouri farm wisdom he'd
say things like shut up boy you're
getting Farm Fresh Food fresh air lots
of free exercise don't ask complicated
questions
so I was glad to get rid of the farm
exercise and go to AG school at the
University of Missouri
and there my major was in animal
husbandry and nutrition my minor was in
field crops and soils and I began to
learn technical things about soil
chemistry and hot related to tons and
bushels per acre but I didn't get a real
answer to my question until I became a
freshman Veterinary student also at the
University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds is simply
because we don't have insurance for them
we don't have Blue Cross Blue Shield
major medical hospitalization Medicare
Medicaid or Hillary to watch out for
them and if we were to use a human
health care type of system for Animals
it'd be sticker shock for everybody your
hamburger would cost you 275 dollars a
pound boneless skinless chicken breast
would be 450 a pound dozen eggs be 50
bucks so we learned that we could keep
the cost of animal products such as meat
and dairy and poultry and eggs down to
where the average person could afford
them simply by reducing or eliminating
the health care cost we do this by
preventing and curing diseases in
animals with nutrition that whole
concept really fascinated me all through
veterinary school and after graduating
vet school I went to Africa for two
years with Marlon Perkins from the old
Mutual of Omaha Wild Kingdom days and
got to play Frank Buck for a couple of
years and use the tranquilizer gun and
trample over Central and South Africa
and after two years Marlon sent me a
telegram and invited me back to St Louis
to work on a big project this was in the
early 60s he'd gotten a seven and a half
million dollar Grant to study pollution
the environment ecology and they needed
a Wildlife veterinarian on the project
and my job
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes and the big zoos
around the United States this of course
included the St Louis Zoo with Perkins
directly the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago
the Bronx Zoo New York the National Zoo
in D.C the LA Zoo and many many other
big zoos around throughout the United
States and my job was to do autopsies on
animals that died of natural causes and
to look for a species of animals that
was Ultra sensitive to pollution and
we're going to use that animal much like
the old coal miners used to use canaries
remember how that goes they take a
canary in a little cage down in the mine
and if methane gas or carbon monoxide
would leak into the mine the canaries
being more sensitive would drop off the
perch and die and give the men a chance
to get out before they suffocated or
blew up we were supposed to set up
colonies of these animals and strategic
locations around the United States and
if they became ill or died from
pollution we would know that there was
some impending environmental Doom that
we had to deal with to save the human
population that was back in the 60s
now after having worked on this project
for some 12 plus years I had done 17 500
autopsies on over 454 species of animals
plus three thousand human beings for a
comparison and what I learned was that
every animal and every human being who
dies of natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency disease and I got
all excited about this nutrition stuff
again and wrote 75 scientific papers for
medical journals Veterinary journals
International pathology journals
contributed chapters to eight
multi-author textbooks on the subject
wrote one of my own was a thousand Pages
there's two thousand pictures and I
think it cost 140 bucks each medical
students and Veterinary students had to
buy them to pass the course I don't know
if they ever read them but it was one of
those things they had to buy them to
pass the course so we sold a few of
those books and
even though I had tried to get this
information out in standard research
channels through papers and lectures and
whatnot there's lots of competition so I
I really didn't get the interest of the
people who were in power either in
politics or medical research although
things like 2020 with Hugh Downs and
Geraldo I did get to go on that program
before Geraldo got his nose broke for
the first time and it was in 1700
newspapers throughout the world with
that story on UPI and AP
but I really couldn't get anybody
interested we had a lot of competition
we just put men on the moon we had a
high-tech cold war going on with the
Soviets we had declared war on cancer
and committed 23 billion dollars to
finding cures and vaccines in 1971. so I
became frustrated enough I went back to
school for four years up in Portland
Oregon became a physician and I
practiced there for 12 years as a
general family practitioner and
delivered babies and sewed up chainsaw
wounds took care of hemorrhoids all the
things you do as a general family
practitioner but the thing that gave me
the most pleasure was to use everything
I had learned in Veterinary nutrition on
my human patients and it was no surprise
to me it works just in well in people as
it does in animals now I was always very
honest with my patients I put my
Veterinary degree on the wall next to
the medical degree and they'd come in
and they'd spot that and they say Doc am
I in the right place I'm here for a
physical looks like you're a vet and I'd
say look I won't give you a rabies shot
if you don't deserve it
and if I saw that they were from the
farm on their intake survey I used to
keep one of these full length
obstetrical gloves you know I put that
on and kind of wave it in front of their
face like I was going to examine a mare
or a cow right I'd put that on or do a
little AI
and their eyes would get as big as
saucers because they knew right what
that was
and some of them would panic and run out
the door some of it was kind of like
basketball defense you know it was
they'd never turn their back on me
because they're afraid you know
we had a lot of fun the patients and I
and they taught me a lot of useful
things I like to think I gave them some
useful information we're going to go
over that tonight and if you take home
just 10 percent of what I share with you
I believe you're going to save yourself
an enormous amount of unnecessary misery
you're certainly going to save
yourselves a Gob of money and you're
going to add many many healthful years
to your life if you just take home 10
now there's no extra charge if you want
to take home 50 or 100 percent but I'll
sleep well if you take home 10 percent
I always like to start out
by sharing with you that the human being
has the genetic potential to live
healthfully to be 120 to 140. absolutely
no doubt about this everybody in this
room has the genetic capability to live
to be 120 to 140.
unfortunately Americans don't do a very
good job when it comes to longevity
our average lifespan is 75.5 about half
of what we're genetically capable of and
in 1990 when the World Health
Organization examined the top 32
industrialized nations around the world
for a variety of health things longevity
and so forth
we didn't rank very well we ranked 17th
in longevity amongst the top 32 First
World countries that meant that there
were 16 other countries whose peoples
live longer than we do we rank 19th in
healthfulness that meant there were 18
other countries whose peoples live
longer than we do before they developed
diabetes and high blood pressure and
heart disease and arthritis and and
cancer we ranked 23rd when it came to
live births and first year survivability
of babies and were ranked dead last 32nd
out of 32 when it comes to preventing
birth defects and what all these
statistics mean is do we have the
highest priced Health Care system in the
world but not the best
and you're a witness to that if
everything was perfect with your health
or the health of your loved ones if
everything was perfect with the health
care System you'd be home doing
something else tonight and so just the
fact that you're interested to get
additional information for your health
for the health of a loved one says a lot
it's a testimony for what's going on in
the Health Care system today
now everybody has some little ritual
that they do on a regular basis whether
it's daily or several times a day or
several times a week that they believe
will add healthful years to their life
and it ranges from doing exercise
meditation yoga things like wearing
bergenstocks there's things like um
being a vegetarian juicing ripping the
chicken skin off your chicken taking an
aspirin every day all these various
things that we're told to do and Grandma
passes down groups of herbs to you
combinations and so on let's have a look
at three or four and see if there's any
proof in the pudding that there's any
real benefit to these things and let's
start out with what is called the
Paleolithic lifestyle this is where
you're supposed to live and eat like a
caveman now you're supposed to eat
everything raw raw vegetables raw grains
you can't eat any Iowa corn fed beef you
have to chase down low-fat antelopes
with your Birkenstock feet and choke
them to death with your bare hands
because you know a gun and bow and arrow
are inhumane so let's see if there's any
proof in the pudding that there's any
benefit to that type of Lifestyle
and the only real hard evidence we have
here is old otsi atsi of course was a
mummified corpse it was found in the
ottsville Valley of the Italian Alps
when a glacier melted and receded
farther than it had any time in human
history and when they examined this
fellow's corpse they found out that he
was in the Primal life when he died
somewhere between 25 and 40 years of age
they knew he was from the copper age
because all his tools and weapons on his
person were pure copper and that range
between four and six thousand years ago
and the part of this thing that
fascinated me was they did a carbon
dating on his tissues and and narrowed
it down that he had died 5 300 years ago
and they did a series of x-rays on him
to see if he had any of the degenerative
diseases that plague Modern Man things
like cancer and
tuberculosis things like oh syphilis and
so on what they found out was this he
had severe degenerative arthritis of the
circle vertebrae of his neck lumbar
vertebrae of his lower back into both
hips additionally he had hardening of
the arteries he had coronary artery
disease he had heart of the arteries
arterial sclerosis of the AR to
pulmonary artery and the iliac arteries
going down into both of his legs and I
guarantee you he didn't eat three eggs
for breakfast every morning certainly
didn't eat any Big Macs he didn't eat
any Iowa corn fed beef all of the things
that are blamed on these types of
degenerative diseases so there is no
proof in the pudding that the
Paleolithic lifestyle has any health or
longevity benefit then there's the
meditation and yoga the body mind Spirit
thing that was brought to the United
States during the 60s and 70s by the
flower children the hippies kind of died
out for a while and has been reawakened
in the last couple of years by Deepak
Chopra who's written I don't know at
least five best-selling books on the
subject
let's see if there's any proof in the
pudding that meditation and yoga have
any longevity or health benefit
Rita Guerra age 55 and and thought to be
the premier meditation and yoga
instructor in the Western Hemisphere was
the director of the Himalayan Institute
in Chicago she was a vegan a type of
vegetarian that doesn't eat any animal
products whatsoever and she thought she
was so spiritually elevated she didn't
need to supplement any of her diet with
vitamins and minerals and as a result
she died at age 55 from a simple
deficiency of a trace mineral called
selenium a cardiomyopathy heart attack
so there's no proof in the pudding that
the body mind Spirit approach meditation
and yoga has any health or longevity
benefit can calm you down during tax
season and finals week but no Health and
Longevity benefit then there's this
organic food movement which has been
around since Adele Davis and people
mistakenly believe that organically
grown food is is healthier for you from
the standpoint of nutrition than is
non-organically grown food and organic
means is just grown without sprays no
herbicides or pesticides and certainly
is safer from the standpoint of cancer
but what about everything else well
certainly it doesn't work very well
because it just means there's no sprays
on it says nothing there's no warranty
or guarantee that there's more vitamins
or minerals in there there was a guy who
wrote two best-selling books on the
subject The Secret Lives of plants and
the secrets of the soil's name was Chris
bird Christopher bird I'd known him for
25 years and I I used to give him as a
present I would just give him minerals
and things
trying to save his life because he had
Snow White hair and we'll talk about
that in a minute and he just poo pooed
he says I'm eating organically grown
food I don't need to take anything else
and I was in about three weeks ago I was
in the airport in Atlanta reading the
local newspaper and guess whose obituary
is in there in big bold letters
Christopher Byrd I wrote The Secret
Lives of plants and the secrets of the
soil 68 years old he drops dead from a
stroke even though he was eating nothing
but organically grown food
so there is no proof in the pudding that
that in of itself has any health or
longevity benefit then there's the
subject of meat A lot of people say oh
you can't live to be healthful if you
eat a lot of meat you got to give up
meat you have to be a vegan or a
vegetarian of some type or another and
I've listened to that for years and of
course my personal Credo is that a day
without a hamburger is like a day
without sunshine
so
I was happy to see this I was up in
Colorado last week and they found it in
Colorado there's 400 people over the age
of 100 they're 105 and 109 and and so
forth there's 400 people over the age of
100 and the only Common Thread they're
different races and different religions
and have different dietary Lifestyles
but the only Common Thread between all
these 400 people who are over age 100
they're heavy meat eaters
they're heavy meat eaters is the only
common thread
so yes for us meteors
then there's say you guys it was worth
your coming here tonight wasn't it
then there's this salt thing you know
everybody oh you got to give up salt
because it causes high blood pressure if
you have high blood pressure you got to
give up salt what's the first thing a
good farmer puts out for his livestock
it's about that big it's a salt block
right and of course I refuse to believe
that my patients are dumber than an old
cow and so I used to tell them hey just
go ahead and take all the salt you want
and people would shrink and and tear and
say well like you're you're flying in
the face of all the weight of medical
evidence you're going to kill people
telling them to Salt their food and of
course there never is there never was
and there never will be any weight of
medical evidence that said salt is bad
for you it certainly does not cause high
blood pressure
this came out just a couple of days ago
May 22nd Wednesday May 22nd just about a
week ago now and there was a study that
was done
it came out in Jama the journal the
American Medical Association the most
prestigious
medical journal in the world
they looked at 56 studies that had been
done around the world on salt and high
blood pressure they combined them into
one study and some doctors from Toronto
Medical School up at the University of
Toronto researched all this and they
said hey
people who have normal blood pressure
there's no benefit to restricting your
salt intake it does not protect you from
high blood pressure if you have high
blood pressure only five percent of the
people with high blood pressure get any
benefit from restricting salt only five
percent and then they only reduce their
blood pressure by 3.7 millimeters of
mercury if your blood pressure is up 25
30 40 points it's kind of stupid to give
up salt for other reasons because it has
nothing to do positively for your health
what he did say over here was that
there's so many doctors that have a
vested interest in getting people off
the salt that they told them to get off
the salt you have to keep coming in and
getting medicine and water pills and
this that and the other why would they
tell you to go ahead and salt your food
and stay home and enjoy yourself you
know and so there is no proof in the
pudding that getting salt out of your
diet has any health or longevity benefit
one more then we'll get into the
longevity thing this last one
is the subject of the Mediterranean diet
this is the one that the medical
profession has jumped on they say the
Mediterranean diet is the answer for the
Health and Longevity and Optimal Health
and what they want you to do is give up
red meat and eat lots of chicken and
poultry and lots of fruit and vegetables
a little wine was okay according to the
Mediterranean diet but there is no proof
in the pudding that it has any health or
longevity benefit because the Greeks and
the Italians who eat the most of it live
to be 75.5 just like us
and here's a hard example
Pope John Paul II
Corsa is the pope of all the Catholics
and and big Catholic population in Italy
and you'd like to think that if anybody
in Italy was getting the very best that
the Mediterranean diet would have to
offer to be the pope he's 76 years old
just turned 76 years old two years ago
had his hips replaced because of
degenerative arthritis and osteoporosis
he has failing Health he has to cancel
half of his speaking engagements and
half of his administrative duties he
just simply does not have enough
strength to do that anymore
and 76 is about half of what we're
genetically capable of when it comes to
longevity so unless he's been sneaking
in Polish sausage under the table for
the last 17 years since he's been in
Rome there is no proof in the pudding
that the Mediterranean diet has any
health or longevity benefit
let's have a look at just how old you
can live to be if you do everything
right is it worth going to a little
effort I believe it is and I'm going to
prove it to you
Christian Mortensen here in August of
1995 about what almost nine months ago
now turned 113 plays golf once a week
looks like he's about 85 years old looks
pretty good for 113. and this gal here
Dora ramothebe from South Africa turned
114 in July of 1995 and when the media
and the Press ran to her and said Dora
what do you attribute Your Health and
Longevity to she did not say I owe it
all to my HMO
she did not say hey I never failed to
take that invitation and go in for my
annual physical what she said was this
I eat Locust every day you know
grasshoppers
pumpkin seeds tortoise meat not a
vegetarian wild herbs dried fruit and
starts each day with a cup of coffee so
we're beginning to connect the dots and
put together what it takes to live to be
over a hundred
don't rush to the bait store because
crickets won't work it has to be
grasshoppers
this gal here Gene Calment
from France in February February 21st
1995 turned 120 and was documented by
the Guinness World Book records as being
the oldest living woman in the world and
she rode her bike until she was 105
years of age and we volunteered as a
librarian in the Paris Library and then
a year later February 21st 1996 just a
couple months ago she turned 121 and she
still documented as the oldest living
woman in the world by the Guinness World
Book of Records
this fellow here from a little town
outside of Bogota Colombia's name was uh
or is he's still alive Francisco chop
Arena
when he was asked by reporters what did
he attribute his Health and Longevity to
he said he drinks a gallon of goat's
milk every day and the part that
fascinated me about his birthday story
is that 40 years ago his doctors told
him he only had a couple of months to
live
and his sons built him a coffin and
every morning for 40 years he's been
waking up sitting by that coffin waiting
to die night time comes he goes to bed
wakes up sits by the coffin waiting to
die he's been doing that every morning
for 40 years because doctor told him he
was going to die in a couple of months
probably didn't have a calendar yeah
and of course all the doctors who told
him that 40 years ago are long since
dead
in addition to Turning 125 and still
going strong he was still fathering
children at age 90. so there's hope for
some of you guys going to sleep in the
back of the room already
this gal here Mizumi Dusty from Iran
according to the Iranian news agency
this was in the Rocky Mountain news from
Denver a little over about a year and a
half ago now January 1995. she died at
age 161. and the interesting thing about
her obituary to me is that she was
survived by six living children
ranging in age from 120 to 128. they had
never even left home to go to college
yet
and her oldest son Golem said his mother
had never visited a doctor nor taken any
chemical medications or drugs or
Pharmaceuticals did take a few herbs
during her life so again we're beginning
to collect more information of what it
takes to live to be over a hundred now
let's look at a a fellow from the United
States who is a favored son of course I
believe especially for people who are
interested in Alternative Health Linus
Pauling Linus Pauling was famous for a
variety of reasons number one he is one
of two people to ever get two unshared
Nobel prizes certainly one of the
Geniuses of our Century maybe of all
time he was also famous for his interest
in vitamin C
and he was trained in classical
biochemistry and nutrition in medical
schools and and universities and so he
believed you could get all of your
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
amino acids and fatty acids from eating
your four food groups but he also
believed that you needed to take extra
vitamin C because of the pollution or
air water and food and because of all
the stresses of modern day life
and so he personally took 10 000
milligrams of Vitamin C every day for 35
years never miss a lick 10 000
years and he still died seven years
short of the magic number of 100 died at
age 93 and he died of widely
disseminated prostate cancer
well after reading all of his materials
and scientific articles and nutritional
journals and Physiology journals and so
on and an additional 400 articles by
various authors on vitamin C here's what
I can guarantee you
if you Faithfully take 10 000 milligrams
of Vitamin C every day for 35 years like
Linus Pauling did and you're a woman I
will guarantee you that you will never
get prostate cancer
as the only guarantee I can make about
vitamin C
there's absolutely no doubt that the
human being can live to be 120 to 140
people do it all the time
well after spending many many years
perhaps 30 years looking and reading and
studying on Health and Longevity in both
Veterinary journals and human medical
journals here's what I can tell you no
matter how you look at Health and
Longevity there's really only two basic
concepts that you have to be concerned
with Concept number one I refer to as
avoid stepping on the landmines this is
where you don't want to throw away your
life wastefully you don't want to smoke
you don't want to abuse alcohol
certainly don't do drugs don't jog down
the highway at two o'clock in the
morning wearing an all-black ninja suit
you're gonna get hit by a truck mirror
right you don't want to jump out of a
hot air balloon from 250 foot up with a
300 foot bungee cord
the math doesn't work out
then there's a lot of crazy things
people do certainly lastly I would say
you want to avoid going to a medical
doctor because given half a chance they
will kill you
now as flippant as this might sound to
some of you and I know there may be some
health professionals in here tonight and
I applaud you for being here if you are
this happens to be from April 14 1996
the Sunday supplement magazine Parade
Magazine many newspapers around America
and they did a whole special issue on
when doctors are the problem I've been
talking about this for 25 years and so
this is they're kind of what 25 years
late but better late than never in this
case in in April excuse me in January
January 13th of 1993 January 13th 1993
Ralph Nader came out the results of a
three-year study on hospitals and and
deaths and infections and injuries that
occurred in those hospitals 1500 pages
and there's all kinds of things that he
said but I'm going to give you one of
the bottom lines which just was a
shocker to me said quote 300 000
Americans are killed each year and
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote three hundred
thousand
to appreciate how big a figure that is
remember he used the word killed that
means that somebody did something to
them to dispatch them they didn't just
die accidentally they were killed
according to Ralph Nader not me let's
compare that with 10 years of military
operations in Vietnam and over that 10
years we had lost 56 000 military
personnel for an average of 5 600 a year
and for these military losses millions
of people poured out in the streets and
protested we had political Anarchy the
last three years of that 10-year War we
chased a president out of the presidency
and God forgive us we shot and killed
American students in Kent State Ohio
demonstrating against that war this was
for 5 600 military personnel a year now
comes Ralph Nader and says here's one
profession or one trade who kills 300
000 Americans a year
through negligence and you can't even
find a crazy Street Preacher out here in
any Corner protesting it well who is it
that they kill is it just the homeless
they go under the bridges and you know
things like that and get the homeless
and take them to the teaching hospitals
take them down in the basements and
practice on them
it's not that simple of course it's a
little more complicated
uh well let's see we got 600 plus people
in here tonight how many of you remember
Betsy Layman anybody remember the name
Betsy Layman okay not a single soul I'm
gonna remind you who Betsy Layman was
just about a year ago April of 1995
um
Betsy Layman who was the Pulitzer
prize-winning medical reporter from the
Boston Globe the second largest
newspaper in America 39 years old
developed breast cancer and she sat down
by her computer and scientifically
examined all the cancer treatment
centers in the world not just her own
Hometown and she looked at the
successful ones and who had terrible
safety records and who was on The
Cutting Edge of research for breast
cancer and she chose the Dana-Farber
Cancer Institute in Boston as her cancer
treatment center and she went in for her
first and what turns out to be her last
chemotherapy treatment they killed her
with a 16 times overdose
they gave her four day dose every day
for four days and they killed her now
because she was famous she was written
up in Time Magazine and and in every
newspaper in America because again she
was a Pulitzer prize-winning medical
reporter for the Boston Globe but
remember there was still 299 999
Americans killed
in 1995 by the medical profession
according to Ralph Nader
she was just one that was highlighted
now this one here
I'm going to share this last one with
you and I want to absolve everybody
involved with this presentation tonight
including the Civic Center and
yourselves and any company involved and
so forth this is my own personal thing
and if anybody gets arrested sued or
assassinated it will be me so you're
absolved of any of this Danger
you recognize this gal here as a
photograph a little fuzzy because I
lifted it out of a magazine and the
reason why I like this photograph of
Jackie Kennedy is that it was taken of
her three days before she entered the
hospital in New York for her first and
what turned out to be her last
chemotherapy treatment for cancer she
was taking a stroll in this picture in
Central Park in New York in a Brisk day
with a friend and
she was diagnosed six months before her
death is having Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma
which is a type of cancer that normally
takes 10 12 15 years to kill you it's
relatively painless say in comparison to
pancreatic cancer which can kill you in
three to six months and be
excruciatingly painful
and when she went in for her first
chemotherapy treatment there was no
death watch on her because there was no
anticipation she was going to die after
all she had 10 12 15 years left to go
goes in on Friday night Tuesday she's
dead you're supposed to believe that
Jackie Kennedy died of cancer
well as a pathologist and a clinician
I'll guarantee as sure as God made
little green apples Jackie Kennedy did
not die of cancer
she died of an overdose of chemotherapy
just like Betsy Layman
and if they can kill a Jackie Kennedy
and they can kill a Betsy Layman and not
a single thing happened to any of those
doctors they weren't sued they weren't
dismissed their licenses weren't
suspended nothing happened to those
clinics or hospitals what chance is the
average person on the street have
not very much
now here's another survey that Ralph
Nader did
in July of 1994 and this one he looked
at the relationship between Doctors
medical doctors and seniors people over
age 65. this happens to be from the
front page of the USA Today I just like
the color pictures it was in every
newspaper in America and what this study
said was this seventy percent of the
doctors who treat Medicare patients
flunked the exam on how to prescribe to
the elderly safely and effectively 70
percent flunked the exam
and what would happen to American
Airlines if 70 of their pilots flunked
the examine how to fly
what would happen to American Airlines
if they killed 300 000 passengers a year
you see all this big hoo-ha going on
over the Value Jet where they killed 109
people right now the reason why this
difference is this
when a jet goes down and splatters parts
of people's bodies you know say 200
passengers over a hillside or a swamp
it's pretty hard to hide and so you know
it's a kind of a gruesome thing
but in the medical profession it's more
subtle than that obviously if doctors
were to line up cancer patients and and
AIDS patients and people with diabetes
along the wall and Mom down a machine
gun to save money for treatment then
people would protest because that's very
blatant but here's one of the many
examples that Ralph Nader gave as to why
this is missed because people are busy
with their lives you have kids and
grandkids you have jobs and and things
to do and so you're not going to sit
there and kind of keep an eye on things
you assume that somebody else is doing
it well here's what Ralph Nader said 32
000 hip fractures each year in America
are attributed to prescriptions or
prescribing by medical doctors that
leaves the elderly sedated and
unbalanced and they fall over and
Fracture a hip trying to avoid stepping
on the kid or getting out of the tub
getting out of the car and this is a
death sentence for 29 000 of these
people remember 75 over the age of 65
don't live 90 days they do have
complications pneumonia a stroke and
Pulmonary embolism and others
and I believe that doctors should be
held responsible for this just the way
that bartenders are when they let people
drink too much and drive home and kill
somebody else or themselves and there's
manslaughter and second-degree murder
and wrongful death however you know
whatever applies to that case there is
an organization called mad Mothers
Against Drunk drivers because there's 15
000 Americans every year killed by drunk
drivers any members of mad in this
audience tonight MADD any members yeah
there's a couple
anyway
I believe they should redirect their
energies towards Physicians because
Physicians according to Ralph Nader
killed 300 000 Americans a year and they
don't even have to change their towels
or their letterhead they could keep
their initials mad just change their
name to Mothers Against dumb doctors
thank you
yeah a couple of more in concept number
one I think you'll have the idea one of
my favorite surveys it was done by
Harvard Medical School was published in
1972 what they did was look at the the
drug use both the illegal street drug
use and the illegal use prescription
drugs by medical doctors on themselves
on a weekly basis what they found out
was pretty shocking they found out that
52 percent of licensed medical doctors
in America use psychotropic drugs on
themselves
each and every week
this included cocaine marijuana speed
barbiturates opium derivatives and
things like Fentanyl
so what that means is if you choose to
go to a doctor for every little thing
when you leave here tonight don't be too
excited about their degrees and
certificates and and licenses hanging on
the wall what you want to do is very
carefully look at the pupils of their
eyes and see if they're gorked out on
something before you let them examine
you are prescribed to you or do any kind
of procedure
even scarier to me is that 78 percent of
the medical students in America use
psychotropic drugs on themselves
illegally each week and down deep in
your heart do you really believe that
when they graduate school and go out and
practice do they quit using drugs
no they can get the good stuff now
because they're making money right
here's an example I have thousands of
these but here's an example
Dr Michael a potler 30 years old just
about three years out of his residency
we knew he was a kind of Doctor Who was
going to be in trouble because he's
wearing bergenstocks right
now he killed himself an overdose of of
drugs and you know he gave himself an
intravenous injection a recreational
thing and killed himself because he was
a medical doctor they eulogized him on
the front page of the San Diego
newspaper he saved the lives of children
but lost his own and in the article said
he devoted his whole life to caring for
children
now unless he was a babysitter a
pedophile most of his life that had to
be a lie because he was only out of his
residency for three years
additionally he was a thief because of
drugs he killed himself with he stole
out of the hospital pharmacy he was
additionally malignant dumb
because after 14 years of medical school
he still couldn't read the syringe right
and killed himself in an overdose
I mean these kids who dropped out of
high school and can't even read write
and do math live in cardboard boxes they
drew drugs every year forever and ever
and ever
and don't kill themselves
and this is from the editorial page of
the Washington Post Washington D.C
November 2nd 1992. lining docks Pockets
if you go to a doctor or your doctor you
want him to think of you as a patient
not a cash cow but two studies in this
month's New England Journal of Medicine
shows that doctors are out to milk you
dry and if you're from a farm you know
what that means what a cash cow is
ten months later and the Readers Digest
very interesting article of September
1993 and to me the Reader's Digest is
the sweetest little magazine that ever
was never never says anything negative
about anyone or any individual or any
group and so I was really surprised to
see this and on page 77 it says can you
trust your doctor and it lists 12 ways
that doctors routinely scam patients
I'll give you the worst one you can go
look up the other 11. September 1993.
the worst one according to Reader's
Digest not me the average doctor in
America gets 421 dollars in Kickbacks
every time he refers somebody in for a
CAT scan or an MRI you thought doctor
loved you and he said you know we've
been fighting that bursitis in that
shoulder for five years and giving you
heroic injections of cortisone in there
and it's just getting worse let's you
know you've got good insurance and
you've got good Medicare supplements not
going to cost you anything let's run you
in and see if that bird sinus is really
arthritis
Ching 421 bucks
now
according to Reader's Digest not Joel
Wallach the average doctor in America
gets 226
681 dollars a year
almost a quarter of a million dollars in
CAT scan Kickbacks you wonder why health
care costs keep spiraling upwards
now the best way to keep track of
doctors and keep a scorecard on them is
to look at the obituaries in your town
and it's not gruesome but you should
look in there and if everybody is dying
in their 50s that should give you some
concern
you know everybody should be dying their
80s and 90s and hundreds if everybody's
dying of kidney disease you don't want
to go to the urologist in your town so
you know just kind of take a glance
through the obituaries and see if
there's any kind of picture that's
developing here
about a year and a half ago this
obituary appeared in the San Diego
newspaper and it's a national level
tragedy obituary Grace masira age 48
died of a widely disseminated breast
cancer horrible thing it used to be a
disease of older women today it's a
disease of teenage girls it's one of
those things that's gotten worse over
the years and there's a variety of
reasons for this but certainly
chemotherapy and radiation has not
solved the problem but anyway this
little headline here given radiation as
a baby I want to know what that had to
do with the obituary so I read her
obituary and says when she was six
months of age her pediatrician
shrank her thymus gland with radiation
from an x-ray machine because he didn't
know what else to do she was kind of a
sickly kid and they you know they took
out her tonsils or adenoids and said
well there's nothing else to do let's
just shrink her thyroid excuse me her
thymus gland so what a terrible thing to
do who on Earth would do such a thing
everybody knows your thymus gland is
there to activate your killer T cells
and protects you from viruses and cancer
and that sort of thing nobody in the
right mind would do such a thing so I
went into the medical literature between
1945 and 1950 and looked at all the
pediatric medical journals and sure
enough
it was common practice back then because
the Army and Navy had given all the
medical doctors America free x-ray
machines when they closed down all these
field hospitals and this that and the
other and they gave these Mobile X-Ray
machines all the doctors hey go out and
try them doc you know you're a doctor
and uh there was common practice and
according to the U.S department of
energy one million American babies under
the age of one year had their thymus
gland shrunk between 1945 and 1950. one
million not a single foreign enemy has
ever radiated in America neither
civilian or military and the one
profession who says well trust me my
dear radiated one million American
babies now according to the American or
the U.S department of energy these kids
have either already died of cancer
they're currently under treatment for
cancer or they project they're going to
die of cancer based on the amount of
radiation they receive to their neck and
chest to shrink their thymus glands
now you wonder what the pupils look like
on the eyes of this surgeon up in Grand
Rapids Michigan about a year ago when he
took off the normal breast left the
cancers one on no sober surgeon can make
that mistake I mean even if he was
dyslexic he couldn't make that mistake
because if he's dyslexic the surgical
nurses know that and they'll take a red
wax pencil and put a bull's-eye on the
correct breast and put a red ribbon on
the guy's wrist and say Doc just match
the colors even a dyslexic can match
colors so you know this guy had to be
gorked out on something
and uh the poster child as it turns out
for Americans who've been injured and
killed in American hospitals turns out
to be the name of a guy by the name of
Willie King Willie King went into the
university a community hospital in Tampa
Florida to get his right leg amputated
he had uncontrolled diabetes he had
gangrene and that leg the bones were
sticking out of his toes and his skin
was slipping off and his flesh smelled
like rotten meat in a garbage can on a
hot July night and the surgeons promptly
cut off his normal left leg
now it turned out okay for Willie
because they cut off his other leg for
free
kind of balanced him up a little bit
a couple more I think you'll have the
picture
Dr Raymond Sattler a neurosurgeon from
North Carolina
got his license suspended for 30 days
according to this article because he
left the surgical room after he had
exposed the patient's brain to the ear
he left the patient's brain exposed for
25 minutes and it'll dry it out a little
bit and well he ran out and got some
lunch now I don't believe that was the
case because I've done a lot of surgery
and when you get to the point where
you're kind of dancing around you know
when you have to go to the bathroom or
you're hungry it's not the sort of thing
that you're going to leave a patient
what you do is you go faster you put the
stitches farther apart you put fewer in
but you get it done before you leave
and I believe that this fellow is one of
those 52 of the medical doctors who do
drugs every week and had to run into the
bathroom and snort some cocaine or give
himself an injection to calm himself
down and I based his opinion on remarks
and statements from the Medical Board of
North Carolina and they said Dr Raymond
Sattler forgot the names of surgical
instruments during the operation and
told his nurse to drill holes in the
patient's head with a Black and Decker
drill
and there's like Sears home repairs
and she didn't know what she was doing
she injures the patient so he got his
license suspended for 30 days
his fellow here is a chest surgeon in
Fort Worth Texas he is on the staff of
the osteopathic medical center of Texas
and took out the normal right lung and
left the cancerous left lung in I
guarantee you he immediately knew that
because whenever you remove something
that has cancer in it you always take
your scalpel and you cut through it
several times take a representative
sample put in some preservative and send
it to the lab so they can tell you
exactly what's going on there so you
know how to pursue treatment
this guy knew immediately and of course
it didn't tell anybody he said well
nobody will know well it just so happens
that this patient went in for autopsy
after he died and the pathologist said
wait a minute the results here at the
autopsy don't jive with a surgical
record and so just to kind of keep
things quiet the surgeons settled for
nine million dollars with the family
never going to a jury and why would he
do that why wouldn't he spend 250 000
worth of of
legal fees when the uh his malpractice
insurance would pay for that
would pay for those legal fees and get
it down to 5 million or 4 million or 2
million he didn't do that well the
reason is I guarantee you he couldn't
find another physician or a nurse who
would testify that he was sober during
the procedure and if that would have
gone before a jury the reward to the
family would have been a hundred million
so he was lucky and glad to get off with
a nine million dollar settlement
now one of the things that I think
should be standard and taught in medical
schools is what a dead patient looks
like what a live patient looks like that
should be standard Death 101 life 101
those should be standard courses but
you're never quite sure that they have
this kind of information when you see
stuff like this
this gal here Mildred C Clarke 86 years
old was found cold stiff and blue in a
nursing home apartment floor and the
house doctor came in and couldn't find a
pulse respiration he said wow she's dead
she's 86 years old let's not go to any
heroic efforts here and run the bills up
for the family and make her miserable in
the last few moments of her life so I
threw her body in the meat wagon and
sent her off to a morg at a little
Hospital in Albany New York but the
house doctor is not going to let you put
a body in the morgue without a death
certificate so he comes down examines
her again couldn't find a a pulse
respiration declares her dead writes a
death certificate turns her body over to
the mortgage technician who promptly
strips her body down hoses her down with
water to clean her up puts her in a body
bag and he Wheels her into a freezer for
90 minutes until the pathologist gets
there to do the autopsy an hour and a
half in the freezer the pathologist and
coroner show up so he Wheels the body
out of the freezer Zips open the body
bag and she sits up
says thank God you found me
it was cold and dark in there and I
didn't know where I was
now she had to be a tough old bird
if you don't believe so get naked hose
yourself down get in the freezer with
the ice cream for 90 minutes and see how
well you do
about five years ago all the medical
doctors in the world got together at a
big International Convention they wanted
to do a study and find out what it was
that drove certain patients to give up
money you know when something happened
and the doctor tried to settle out of
court wave a one million dollar check in
front of people's face one million
dollars tax-free these people say no
money doesn't matter I'm going to take
this doctor before a jury and show that
he's a quack and a fraud and a butcher
and all that sort of stuff they want to
know what it was it turned the patient's
button on to get them to do that what
they found out was this it's always a
patient who felt slighted when they were
in pain or in trouble and the doctor
then did something wrong and hurt them
and this doctor was one who is notorious
for coming in the examining room you're
laying there in your gown or naked on
the on the couch or the examining table
and um
kept looking at your watch and looked at
the record never touched the patient or
shook their hand or talked to them
directly in their eyes but just looked
at the record and say okay I'm gonna
write your prescription ran out the door
and calling to his nurse to get his car
up because he had a golf appointment
these are the ones that patients just
wanted to go after him and you shouldn't
be too surprised that this is the
approach that the medical profession has
taken to prevent those types of suits
this is from the Lancet the top British
medical journal of top International
medical journal and it was two
professors of medical ethics from the
medical school at the University of
Western Ontario up in Canada
and what they said was this acting
classes should be required in medical
school so doctors can learn just when to
provide a perfectly timed compassionate
look or a touch on the hand and that was
supposed to avoid all these suits where
patients thought the doctors didn't like
them
so if you go to a doctor for every
little thing you don't know if they're
acting or not they don't you don't even
know if they know if you're alive or
dead you don't know if they're gorked
out on something or sober you don't know
if they're going to give you one of
those 70 of the prescriptions that are
going to kill you these are all reasons
why you want to avoid stepping on the
landmines get as much information as you
can yourself make as many of your own
decisions as you can save yourself
unnecessary risk that's concept number
one concept number two these are all the
positive things that most of you are
here for tonight these are the positive
things that you can do to direct
yourself towards reaching 120 to 140 and
basically what you want to do is give
your body all the raw materials it
requires to maintain and repair itself
most of us don't think in those terms we
require maintenance materials just like
any machine if you will that a tractor
can you run a tractor or a car without
coolant and oil no you wouldn't think of
it and yet you know the equivalent we
try to do that for own body so let's
look at what we need to maintain
ourselves and repair ourselves we need
90 essential nutrients 60 that 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids
and the reason why these things are
called essential nutrients is twofold
number one
our bodies cannot manufacture them we
must consume them every day either in
food or supplements and number two if
any one of these essential nutrients is
missing for six months 12 months a year
two years guess what happens you get on
the average 10 deficiency diseases 10
deficiency diseases times 90 essential
nutrients that's 900 diseases that are
preventable with proper supplementation
and the nice part of this story is if
you've had any of these deficiency
diseases for 5 10 15 20 30 years and you
start supplementing because you just
learn about this you have every honest
expectation of getting significantly
better maybe even 100 better so you have
everything to gain and nothing to lose
by considering this as we've learned
tonight the media is interested in what
you're interested in because it sells
newspapers so to speak they sell a lot
of newspaper if they have a nice story
and everybody runs out to get one if you
hear a radio program that everybody's
interested in they sell more
advertisement so this is why you hear a
lot of health programs on Radio and on
TV and you'll see it in newspapers and
magazines
and my personal favorite of all the
health articles was this one here April
6 1992 a little over four years ago it
was the first time that the subject of
vitamins and minerals was treated in a
positive way by any mainstream
publication Time Magazine no less cover
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and ravages of
Aging prior to this article mainstream
magazines would only say things like
well vitamins and minerals are quackery
and hoax and fraud charlatanism nobody
needs those things you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups now if you haven't read that
article again April 6 1992 I'd urge you
to go to a Library Public Library School
library dig it out and read it there are
six positive pages
there was only one negative sentence and
as you might guess it was offered by a
medical doctor who was asked by the
writer of the article what do you think
about vitamins and minerals for human
nutrition here's what he said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do any good
sniffs Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote now Missouri translation
of that is you're just peeing away your
money
might as well wad up your dollars and
throw them in the toilet and flush them
away you know you get everything you
need from your four food groups that
little sentence has killed more
Americans than all of the foreign
enemies with their rifles and artillery
put together you can get everything you
need from your four food group it is not
true believe me it's not true now and I
can guarantee you after having done
those seventeen thousand five hundred
autopsies and over 454 species of
animals plus three thousand human beings
for a comparison having practiced for 12
years in Portland Oregon as a general
family practitioner pushing 60 myself
and having kids this tall and grandkids
this big and not too distant future
great grandkids I'd rather pee out
50 cents or a dollar a day worth of
excess vitamins and minerals that's
cheap insurance if you don't invest 50
cents to a dollar a day in yourself as
sure as God made little green apples
you're going to invest in the lifestyle
of a medical doctor because when you pay
them hard cash out of your own pocket or
indirectly through insurance or
indirectly through taxes and Medicare
not a single penny of that goes to
better understand manage treat prevent
or cure catastrophic diseases in kids
breast cancer in women prostate cancer
and Men diabetes heart disease cataracts
it pays the doctor's mortgage pays a
doctor's mortgage no matter how you're
struggling with your bills it pays a
doctor's mortgage and when you pay the
doctor after the second week of the
month you're paying his Mercedes payment
you pay the doctor after the third week
of the month you're paying the tuition
for their kids to go to medical school
at Harvard our worst yet Yale Law School
it's always there's a bunch more Yale
lawyers running around
we got a whole White House full of them
and look what's going on in there
[Applause]
well we could get into that I mean
that's why they call me the Rush
Limbaugh of Alternative Health
okay now one of the things that I used
to do for my patients was send them a
two cent photocopy a little article I'd
find in newspapers and nutritional
journals and medical and Veterinary
journals things that they could do
themselves nutritionally or with herbs
or whatnot and got to be quite a thing
250 000 people a month one of these two
cent photocopies so I turned it into a
magazine that comes out every couple of
months but I'm going to show you what I
used to give my patients and what you
two can can get let's start out with
cancer the number two killer of adults
the United States if you take nothing
else home tonight but this piece of
information it was worth your coming
this little study
was done by the National Cancer
Institute
and they went to henan Province China
for five years and they chose henan
Province China because it has the
highest rate of cancer and cancer deaths
in the whole world they took 29 000
apparently healthy people ranging in age
from 40 to 69 and they divided them up
into little groups and gave each group a
different vitamin different minerals
sometimes combinations of vitamins and
minerals and after five years they
untangled the study and here's what they
found if you've got a single nutrient
not much positive happened when it came
to reducing the death rate from cancer
and not too surprising vitamin C didn't
do much by itself Linus Pauling took ten
thousand milligrams of Vitamin C every
day for 35 years still died of cancer
retinol or vitamin A didn't work zinc
riboflavin the trace mineral molybdenum
niacin none of these things worked as
single nutrients but one group showed
significant benefit they took three
nutrients doubled the American RDA I
mean a pitifully low dose double the
American RDA 20 cents a day
beta-carotene vitamin E and the trace
mineral selenium and they showed a
reduction in deaths from all causes by
nine percent this included suicide
pneumonia and car wrecks and cancer and
diabetes and heart disease and aneurysms
and whatnot reduced deaths from all
causes by nine percent they reduce all
cancers regardless of the type of cancer
by 13 and the type of cancer most
prevalent in henon Province stomach and
lower esophageal cancer they reduced by
21 saved almost one out of four simply
by taking in three nutrients
beta-carotene vitamin E and selenium
now don't wait for your doctor or your
government to give you this information
if they haven't already yelled at you or
sent you an Urgent health program or had
their nurse call you they're not going
to do it I mean we're talking this was
two and a half years ago
so that you need to just take the bull
by the harms and do it yourself
now my very favorite disease
I call it my favorite disease if you
have such a thing as a favorite disease
is arthritis and the reason why I like
arthritis it very clearly shows people
what they can do for themselves and once
you get enough confidence in dealing
with a disease you say well gosh maybe I
can be this good working with another
one and so on and so it kind of gives
you that confidence you need to make
some decisions on your own without
having to ask a doctor for everything
now there's not a single medical
treatment designed to fix arthritis you
have 75 of all Americans over the age of
50 get it to one kind or one degree or
another and according to the CDC the
Center for Disease Control over the next
seven to ten years 35 million baby
boomers of whom there's quite a few in
this room are going to get it there's
not a single medical treatment designed
to fix it by contrast in veterinary
medicine we're encouraged to find
nutritional formulas that are designed
to to prevent and cure all kinds of
diseases and animals including arthritis
so the advantage my patients had was I'm
a veterinarian as well as a physician so
I went into my Veterinary background and
I took all these Veterinary formulas
designed to prevent and cure arthritis
and in chickens and turkeys and
pheasants and pigeons and dogs and cats
and sheep and pigs and horses and cows
and lions and tigers and bears
and uh and adapted them to human use and
I came up with what I call Dr wallach's
Pig arthritis formula not because
there's any pigs in there but because it
was used to prevent and cure arthritis
in pigs now this little formula over the
last 20 plus years I have literally seen
regrow collagen bone in literally tens
of thousands of people right now there's
over a quarter of a million people a
month using Dr wallach's Pig arthritis
formula and it's going up at a rate of
three to four thousand new people a
month and the reason is of course it
works now the medical profession would
differ with this they'd say now Wallach
that's absolutely not true everybody
knows you can't regrow Carlton bone when
you have bone to bone arthritis the only
thing left for you medically is to have
joint replacement surgery
and I'd have to agree with them I'd have
to agree with them that if the only raw
materials you're using is aspirin and
Tylenol and gold shots and Methotrexate
and prednisone cortisone
you're not going to regrow Carlton bone
because those are not the raw materials
to do it they have many many side
effects many of which are fatal
when these things over the counter and
prescription medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and these
procedures are all directed towards
relieving pain I mean it's such a
terrible painful disease that people are
willing to let surgeons cut out their
knees and their hips and their shoulders
in any attempt to relieve pain
so I came up with Dr wallach's Pig
arthritis formula well Harvard Medical
School is laid in the bushes for me for
25 years and he said we've finally found
a way to prove that Wallach is a quack
and a fraud in charlatan because
everybody knows you can't regrow
collagen bone and they took what they
thought was the most ridiculous
one-third of Dr wallach's Pig arthritis
formula and they gave it to 29 patients
who had failed to respond in any way to
heroic medical treatment for arthritis
over 15 to 20 years they took them off
all their medication wasn't doing any
good anyway and the only thing left for
them medically was joint replacement
surgery and they gave him a heaping
tablespoon full of ground up chicken
cartilage and orange juice every morning
for 90 days just three short months
and here's what happened
after 10 days they had complete relief
of pain and inflammation something they
hadn't had in 15 to 20 years in 30 days
they could Now open up a new pickle jar
that never had been opened without
paying the fingers wrist elbows and
shoulder
in a 90 days just three months according
to Harvard Medical School not me 28 of
the 29 were clinically cured
now you'd think they'd call me up and
say Wallach we got to apologize to you
hey next time you come to Boston come on
in we'll buy you a lobster dinner you
know because gosh even the most
ridiculous one-third of your pig
arthritis formula did some good that's
not what happened don't be too surprised
here's what the medical director the guy
who's a professor of medicine and
Harvard Medical School and pasta and
here's what he said quote
after three months it was clear that the
drug was beneficial unquote chicken
cartilage had become a drug in 90 days
now why would you think that would
happen well because you can't patent
chicken cartilage so they went out to
the U.S patent office and they got to
use patent on chicken cartilage and you
two now for 3 500 bucks a month can get
Harvard Medical Schools chicken
cryogenic capsule arthritis cure 3 500
bucks a month so if this sounds a little
pricey to you all you have to do is go
to Kentucky Fried Chicken buy a five
dollar bucket of chicken throw away the
meat and eat the ends off the bones it's
the same stuff
now if you have several people in your
family that could get a little pricey
you know if you have arthritis so what
you want to do then is go to the
dumpster behind the KFC in the dark of
the night
take your kids or your grandkids give
them an empty five gallon feed bucket
put them in that dumpster let them scoop
out the bones for you
and take them home put those bones on a
cookie sheet put them in an oven bake
them dry pound them into a flower with
your own ball peen hammer and then fill
those chicken car you know those
capsules yourself
and you just don't want to let anybody
know what you're doing because if the
word gets out you know Francine is
making chicken cartilage cabs she's
curing everybody in the neighborhood of
arthritis the FDA is going to come
arrest you in your house for
manufacturing a patented drug
our worse yet they'll send Janet to save
you from yourself and she'll burn your
house down
[Music]
so if you want to avoid all these legal
entanglements and you don't want to get
all those gushy chicken bones all over
your house all you have to do is go to a
good grocery store and get yourself some
either Knox gelatin or Willamette Valley
gelatin unflavored unsweeten it's the
same stuff as the chondroitin sulfate in
there which is the basic building block
to rebuild cartilage and bone bone
matrix bone Foundation if your neck
sounds like a bag full of gravel you got
low back problems loose teeth and all
those kinds of things I want to give Dr
wallach's Pig arthritis for I'm going to
try and I'll give you the full formula
at the end
another one of my favorite diseases is
Alzheimer's disease it's a
physician-caused disease it's a pretty
powerful statement it's a
physician-caused disease we didn't have
Alzheimer's disease 40 years ago was not
in any medical dictionary medical
textbooks it was not taught in any
medical class it only became a disease
entity in 1979.
today according to Ralph Nader it Rivals
cancer and caused three hundred thousand
dollars per patient and it's the number
four killer of adults over the age of 65
behind cardiovascular disease cancer
diabetes then comes Alzheimer's disease
now we eliminated Alzheimer's disease
from animals from 40 years ago can you
imagine a Dairy Farmer with 400 headed
cows on the pasture with Alzheimer's
disease and he's yelling at them and
rattling the feed bucket trying to get
them up to get milk and the cows are all
out there scratching their head saying
why do we want to go to the barn to get
milk
and if we did where's the barn because
it kind of you know
so the farmer has to put fuel in the ATV
and ride out there and hurt them up in
the you know fuel cost goes up labor
cost goes up so they have to raise the
price of milk nobody's happy so we
eliminated Alzheimer's Disease by
eliminating vegetable oil carnal and
soil from the animal's diet and putting
in large doses of vitamin E and selenium
well this is one of those two cent
photocopies you should have gotten from
your doctors three and a half years ago
almost four years ago now this is not
from the National Enquirer
this is from the University of
California San Diego School of Medicine
a very reputable research institution
they said vitamin E can ease memory loss
and Alzheimer's patients
I don't know how many of you saw that
little article and I'm waiting to get a
copy of it so I can make another
overhead just last week
from one of the English universities and
came out and said yeah people take in
800 units of vitamin E every day the
odds of them getting a heart attack are
Alzheimer's disease is almost zero
Alzheimer's disease is an American
disease it does not occur in third world
countries it does not occur in Europe
it's an American disease that's because
all our doctor well I'll tell you in a
minute I'll prove it to you in a minute
there's a
physician cause disease
how many of you heard whether you
believe it or not that vegetable oils
are healthier for the terrible saturated
animal fat whether you believe it or not
raise your hand if you've heard it
that's pretty good about 50 the other
half of you are either asleep lying or
have Alzheimer's because I know you've
heard it
now we learned 50 years ago in the
animal industry that the vegetable oils
were bad for you because we tried to get
animals to gain weight faster by giving
them 20 and 40 percent of the ration as
Cornell or soil because it has double
the amount of calories as does cracked
corn oils have nine calories per gram
and carbohydrate type calories from
either beet pulp or crack corn has
something like four and a half calories
per gram and sure enough for the first
couple of weeks the animals were on the
oils they gain weight many times faster
than ones just getting carbohydrate
calories
but in six weeks they all died of heart
attacks so I mean it was a good idea it
went bad somewhere and they said well
what do we do with this stuff no farmer
is dumb enough to give it to his
livestock anymore and look we've
contracted with Farmers to grow millions
of tons of Cornell and soil every year
for the next 50 years what do we do with
this stuff they said well it's not
proven in human beings yet that it's
dangerous let's convince people that
vegetable oil is good for them and
they've done a pretty good job over the
last 35 40 years haven't they all you
got to do is go into the dairy case I
mean this is really blatant you go to
the dairy case
in the grocery store and you find 85
brands of corn oil margarine in the
dairy case that's how much they
brainwash people you should have gotten
this information three and a half years
ago
vegetable oils can cause heart disease
it's a nightmare said Dr Edward emkin a
specialist in food oils for the U.S
department of Agriculture it's really a
nasty thing we try to explain it there's
now total confusion for consumers why
would there be total confusion for
consumers well that's because the truth
is different from what you've been
taught for 35 years here's another look
at the same problem
margin can increase your risk of heart
attacks a lot of people say to me well
I've got a whole freezer full of tub
margarine can I use that
tub margin stick margin doesn't matter
it's the same thing
this is what they called the Harvard
nurses health study and they took 90 000
nurses over 20 years divided them into
two groups put one group on margarine as
they're spread for their crackers and
bread and cooking shortening but the
other 45 000 nurses on butter where
they're spreading their crackers and
bread and cooking shortening at the end
of the 20 years they looked at their
death certificates and for every hundred
nurses who had died of a heart attack 70
of them were in the margarine group you
have a two and a half times greater risk
of dying of a heart attack if you use
margarine than butter now the biggest
fraud ever perpetuated against the
American people
the biggest fraud ever perpetuate
against the American people is this
cholesterol thing
this is one of those two cent
photocopies you should have got from
your doctors three and a half years ago
top researchers reluctantly admit that
low levels of cholesterol are bad for
you low levels of cholesterol are worse
for you than high levels of cholesterol
this is from the University of
California San Francisco a researcher
who is renowned as the top the top
medical researcher on cholesterol and
cardiovascular disease his name is
Stephen B Holly here's another look at
the same study
three and a half years ago here's what
he said quote what it comes down to is
there's an extraordinary set of
observations that have emerged this year
because for the first time we have a
large enough study to really see them
what he said there was for 40 years
we've been giving you Kaka
you know this stuff is in baby diapers
and um
we didn't really know the truth about
cholesterol so we made stuff up just we
thought it was good for us we made stuff
up but now after 20 years we finally
have the truth now why in this God's
green earth would anybody want to have a
blood cholesterol below 180 always
because a doctor instructed you or
ordered you to do it
now about seven years ago actually it
was May 1st seven years ago I began
lecturing 300 nights out of each year
like this all across the country and in
the beginning the crowds were just three
people then it was 20 and then 50 and
then 100 and for the last five years has
been hundreds and the interest is
growing and people doing things for
themselves and my wife said look I'll
support you on the field if you want to
do that for seven to ten years but it's
gonna you know it's going to take a lot
of toll on you eating Hotel food and
having weird hours and driving all night
to get one place or another what I want
you to do if you're going to do this is
to have yourself a hobby and every time
you feel yourself really getting so
warped out that they're going to come
after you with a butterfly net or
straight racket study this Hobby and get
yourself calmed down before you get in
front of an audience say well that's
good advice I'll do that but after the
hundreds of different things I looked at
I settled on collecting obituaries of
medical doctors
thank you
as my hobby
now the reason was of course it's a very
useful piece of information if doctors
knew what they were talking about when
it came to Health and Longevity if you
separate them out from the rest of the
American population they should be
healthier and live longer than anybody
else and boy was I surprised I started
out a hundred years ago June 15 1895 in
Jama which is the Premier Medical
journal in the world actually generally
American Medical Association and they
did a survey a hundred years ago on
deaths in American doctors once they
found out the average lifespan of
medical doctors 100 years ago was 54.6
54.6 the average population in America
the average lifespan was 62.
now they're in trouble then a hundred
years later January of 1993 I redid the
study using obituaries from the general
American Medical Association just like
they did originally and guess what the
average lifespan for medical doctors
today is 57.6 I gave them the benefit of
the doubt and rounded it up to 58. the
average lifespan for the average
American is 75.5 he gained almost 20
years statistically by not going to
medical school
so I brought you a few of my favorites
so you can see what fun I'm having and
of course all of these are Physicians
who have died of nutritional deficiency
diseases Stuart Cartwright age 38 was
family practitioner good looking kid I'm
sure he could have been a movie actor if
he wanted to I promise you he married
the prom queen and he probably had a
Mercedes convertible in Southern
California probably never repaid a
student loan all the things that medical
students put on their list of wishes
and he dropped dead in his home from a
ruptured coronary artery aneurysm and
the fascinating thing to me is this is
something we learned in turkeys in the
50s 1957 how to prevent in the early
stages reverse
aneurysms and of course this was from a
study at 250 000 turkeys the USDA put on
a complete turkey pellet trying to get
these turkeys to finish for Market
within a week or two of each other as
opposed to strung out all over the whole
summer when they're on pasture and in
the first 13 weeks fully half of them
125 000 of them died farmers were out
there every morning picking them up at a
bushel basket full took them into the
state Diagnostic lab to see what they
died from when they cut them open at
autopsy every one of them had died of a
ruptured aortic aneurysm and one of the
clever Pathologists says Ah that's got
to be due to a copper deficiency because
everybody knows that the elastic fibers
and arteries and skin and other tissues
require a large amount of copper to be
manufactured and the mechanism of an
aneurysm is identical to the mechanism
of a balloon on the weakened wall of a
tire you know when you hit a Chuck hole
and you break the cords in a tire the
internal pressure in the tire blows a
balloon and you thump down the highway
and heat it up it'll blow same way with
an aneurysm when you get a breakdown of
those elastic fibers the internal
pressure in an artery even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon is called
an aneurysm and if it ruptures you bleed
to death
so they got excited about this they
doubled the amount of copper in those
pellets the next year they tried to
raise 500 000 turkeys and they did not
lose a single one from a ruptured
aneurysm they went from a 50 loss to a
zero percent loss simply by adding a
little copper and they got all excited
about this and they started looking at
copper deficient diets and copper levels
and human blood and tissues and what
they came up with was this the very
first symptom of copper deficiency in
human beings is white gray or silver
hair I see a lot of copper deficiency in
this room tonight okay and of course you
don't want to be like a medical doctor
and just color your hair because you
know that's treating the symptom but not
obviously getting down to the root cause
of things if you don't take action at
this point and don't give yourself some
of the right type of copper what's going
to happen is you start getting a
breakdown of the elastic fibers in your
skin and you get crow's feet around the
corners of your eyes and your mouth
parts of your Anatomy begin to Sag and
you know you're in trouble when you go
to your doctor and he says you know I've
got a golf buddy down the hall who's a
plastic surgeon for ten thousand dollars
he'll make you look 20 years younger but
you don't need a booby lift a tummy tuck
or derriere lift or a facial lift all
you need is some colloidal copper and
everything will come back up just like
you have a hydraulic jack under it
now if you don't take action at that
point
you get a breakdown of the elastic
fibers and large veins of your legs you
get varicose veins
don't take action at this point you get
a breakdown of elastic fibers and large
veins of your exhaust pipe and you get
hemorrhoids so if you
if you have hemorrhoids varicose veins
things that sag wrinkles white gray or
silver hair the odds already have
aneurysms developing in you somewhere
and don't be like old frank who dies
suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm and all
his friends get together at Denny's
after the funeral and eating some of
that famous blueberry cheesecake and
they say we never thought Frank would be
the first one to go I mean he was Mr
Fitness
this guy walked five miles before
breakfast every morning he ripped the
chicken skin off the chicken before he
ate it took an aspirin every day he went
to the health club every night and did
those water aerobics with the young
people and he always looked so
distinguished in his gray hair
his body been screaming at him for 25
years Frank give me some copper Frank
give me some copper and he just stood in
the mirror and said man I look like
Einstein you know my gray here
what did Einstein die from a ruptured
aortic aneurysm what color was
Einstein's hair Snow White now this
fellow here Dr Michael PRT is 38 years
old also 20 years before the average for
Physicians and 40 years before the
average American he was a jogger Dr
Michael P Ortiz was a jogger 38 years
old and he encouraged his well patients
to jog with him he gave him a 10
discount on his Services if they would
jog with him a minimum of 15 days out of
each month so he had this big groupy
thing every day that all these patients
were jogging with him because they
wanted this 10 discount and services
well he collapsed and died in front of
his horrified patients while they were
jogging
of a simple cardiomopathy heart attack a
selenium deficiency and because they
didn't want to give up that 10 discount
on the services they all kept jogging
nobody stopped to give him any CPR
[Music]
Martin Carter age 57 one year before the
average for Physicians and uh 20 years
before the average American was an
expert according to the New York Times
obituaries this guy had every drop of
medical education you could get in the
whole world but he didn't have expensive
urine
he didn't have expensive urine even
though his mom and dad were proud of him
the cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm just like those copper
deficient turkeys this is my mother's
favorite obituary she found it I have to
use it all the time keep mom happy
this was what two almost three years ago
now July of 93 Dr Gail Clark age 47 was
the chief cardiologist or hospital she's
walking down the halls of her hospital
to a stethoscope around her neck
she drops dead and let's say you're a
heart patient in the ICU and your
monitor shows you're stable beep beep
beep beep
and then you hear them you know they
close the curtain next to you you don't
know what your doctor being brought in
there you hear them cut the clothes off
they're just yelling for the code cards
and the paddles and contact gel and need
some bicarb and some
um epinephrine that sort of thing and
then you hear them say Okay clear
everybody here we go contact
didn't work okay we need to turn the
panels up more gel more contact y'all
clear clear here we go
then they turn on the monitor
flat line so you know she's dead
we say nurse now your monitor is going
because you're nervous say nurse nurse
what one down next door sound awful with
all the screaming and code cards and
there says you know your cardiologist
the chief cardiologist of this Hospital
Dr Gail Clark h-47 just croaked next
door from a cardio mop of the heart
attack a simple selenium deficiency
disease you see all the patients holding
their gowns and they're running out of
the hospital as fast as they can go
because whatever the chief got they
don't want I mean if it kills the chief
and you know why would you want it
Dr George Kohler the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
he's in the 20th century Dr George
Kohler 37 years old wins the Nobel Prize
in medicine for his uh work with
antibodies monoclonal antibodies he's
going to save people from cancer which
is a righteous type of research 11 years
later age 48
boom drop dead from a cardiomyopathy
heart attack a simple selenium
deficiency disease Because he believes
you could get everything you needed from
your four food groups
I remember I told you when I came back
from Africa
I was supposed to find an early warning
system and it turned out that the early
warning system is not a wombat or a
koala bear a ruby-throated hummingbird
or a rare and endangered fish or reptile
turns out that early warning system is
our own young athletes
according to the CDC the Center for
Disease Control
one hundred thousand young athletes
under the age of 30 dropped dead each
year during exercise or a game or
immediately after exercise or a game one
hundred thousand double the number who
were killed in car accidents
ten years ago I began to see articles
like this in medical journal sudden
death and young athletes and this is a
small study but it gives you a flavor of
what's going on here 29 highly
conditioned competitive athletes ages 13
to 30 drop dead during a game in the
study
35 of them died of ruptured aneurysms
and copper deficiency the other 65
percent died of cardiomyopathy heart
disease a selenium deficiency now what
do you think is the most dangerous sport
in the world you can yell them out to me
boxing basketball
hockey
football
jogging
cross-country racing it turns out that
it is basketball
45 percent
or 45 000 out of the hundred thousand
are basketball players
and I'll show you why in a minute
football happens to be second
here's some of the faces of the Young
Americans these are you know the the
pride of America these are kids who are
healthy apparently and just suddenly
drop dead during games 14 15 16 18 years
old
here's a water polo player 14 years old
cardiomopathy heart disease
15 years old Stanley Hawkins
freshman in high school
just practicing basketball drops over
dead from a cardiomyopathy heart attack
slam deficiency
Darren Malott 22 years old six foot five
had just signed a multi-million dollar
contract with an NBA team
just shooting some baskets and it wasn't
even a game he was in his jeans t-shirt
just shooting some baskets went for a
layup put the ball in the basket came
down he was dead pardon him out with the
heart attack selenium deficiency
here's one that's a little more famous
Reggie Lewis
27 year old captain of the Boston
Celtics April of 1993 a little over
three years ago now
collapsed during a playoff game with the
Charlotte Hornets and was diagnosed very
accurately and very quickly as having
cardiomyopathy heart disease and because
he was a 65 million dollar contract
athlete the Celtics hired the top 12
cardiologists in the whole world and
referred to this collection of doctors
which they accumulated in Boston as the
dream team of cardiologists they called
him the dream team of cardiologists gave
him a million bucks each to refer all
their patients out to other doctors and
lo and behold
they were supposed to devote their full
time to saving Reggie they didn't take
50 bucks of their money and give it to a
medical student or pre-med student to go
to the medical library and like Star
Trek ask the computer computer what are
all the known causes of cardiomyopathy
if they would have done that the
computer would have said there's only
one known cause of cardiomyopathy it was
discovered in animals in 1957 and the
disease was eliminated from animals in
1958. it was proven in human beings in
1972 with a double-blind crossover study
with 45
000 human subjects and the disease was
eliminated in the country in which this
was done
the only known cause of cardiomyopathy
heart disease in both animals and human
beings is a deficiency of the trace
mineral selenium they didn't do that and
as a result they didn't give Reggie
Lewis 10 cents a day worth of selenium
if they would have done that Reggie
Lewis would still be alive today
and as a result while they were
bickering three months after his initial
heart attack Reggie Lewis 27 years old
July 28 1993 dies of a second
cardiomyopathy heart attack
now if the dream team of cardiologists
wouldn't give a 65 million dollar
athlete 10 cents a day worth of selenium
what's the chances of your cardiologist
giving you any
watch my ellipse if you haven't gotten
it by now none
okay I think you get the picture now if
you wait long enough if you wait long
enough justice has a way of coming
around doesn't it
you know my hobby so you shouldn't be
too surprised that a year and a half
after Reggie Lewis died the chief of the
dream team of cardiologists
one Dr W Thomas Nessa a marathon runner
finished the Boston Marathon three times
before he died
was the vice chairman of the Department
of Cardiology at Harvard Medical School
age 48 boom drops dead from a
cardiopathy heart attack
Dr W Thomas Nessa a member of the dream
team of cardiologists
who treated the late Boston Celtics
Captain Reggie Lewis died in his own
home of the same thing I mean this guy
had to be malignant dumb
right I mean he didn't learn anything
from a 65 million autopsy November 1995
Sergey grinkoff two-time Gold Medal
winner of Paris figure skating
1988-1994 in the Olympic Games was just
tying escapes was just tying of skates
at Lake Placid New York getting ready to
get into Peak physical condition for his
upcoming Olympics drops over dead age 28
from cardiopathy heart attack just like
Reggie Lewis age 27.
[Applause]
here's one Matt lachapa backup pitcher
San Diego Padres 20 years old Clemson
died from cardiomopathy heart attack
here's a good story
Evander Holyfield Evander Holyfield was
banned almost three years ago now from
boxing because he developed
cardiomyopathy heart disease not the
sudden type that kills you instantly but
slow wasting in the heart muscle kind of
a muscular dystrophy of the heart muscle
he was banned from boxing because he
couldn't pass the physical anymore about
seven months into his retirement I ran
into one of his physicians in a seminar
like this in Atlanta we talked about the
relationship between selenium deficiency
and cardiomyopathy heart disease they
began to give Evander Holyfield some
selenium
ten months later his electrocardiogram
goes to normal and he passes the
physical
the boxing commission something that
never happens people with cardiomyopathy
heart disease never go back to normal
but then all they get is pacemakers and
heart transplants
at any rate
he passes a physical he boxes about a
year ago wins his first fight back in
the ring three months later he passes a
physical again loses the fight but then
about I don't know six eight weeks ago
passes a physical again four weeks ago
he fought again and won the fight and
he's going strong now simply because he
took some minerals here selenium
if you get into this situation don't let
your doctor tell you only have two
choices either Kevorkian or the heart
transplant
[Music]
you have a third choice and now you're
informed about this so you can make that
decision on your own
the rate of brain cancer in America has
gone up 400 percent in the last 40 years
and everybody's pointing their fingers
towards cellular telephones and
everybody's trying to give me a cellular
telephone so I started examining this it
was there anything to them and you don't
have to worry about it if you use them
because 97 of people who use cellular
telephone or excuse me 97 of the people
with brain cancer have never even been
in the same room with the cellular
telephone let alone use one so you don't
have to worry about that but there is a
little known Trace mineral known as
gallium
this trades mineral gallium
g-a-l-l-i-u-m when you give it to
laboratory animals in optimal amounts
and they can give them a chemical known
to cause brain cancer they don't get it
if you give them a laboratory
experimental diet that's deficient in
gallium and then give them the same
chemical they all get brain cancer so I
believe this huge increase in in rate of
brain cancer in America is a combination
of a gallium deficiency and a lot of
chemicals in our air water and food that
do cause brain cancer
think about all the performers who die
suddenly
whose performances are almost athletic
in their presentation people like Elvis
He died of cardiomopathy heart disease
and because he had lots of drugs in his
blood in his liver they blamed his death
on the drugs but he really died of
cardiomyopathy heart disease which is a
selenium deficiency disease then you
look at Conway Twitty who died in front
of 3 000 fans
in Branson Missouri with a ruptured
aortic aneurysm a copper deficiency
you look at Michael Jackson
collapsed in December of 1995 and was in
the Intensive Care Unit for one week
because his blood minerals and
electrolytes were all messed up almost
died when you go to a basketball game a
football game a track meet look out
there at those well-trained athletes the
odds are all the couch potatoes in the
stands and bleachers have a much better
chance of living to be over 80 than
those athletes do and here I'll put out
my challenge if you can find me an
obituary of any University Semi-Pro or
pro athlete
who's lived the over 100 I'll give you a
hundred dollar bill
because I've looked real hard the
average lifespan for athletes both
University and Semi-Pro and professional
is 62 to 65 depending on their sport
Here's the final clue
as many as 62 percent of the female
college gymnasts suffer from anorexia
they suffer from anorexia 62 is that
because it's genetic no is that because
all their mothers hate them no is it
because they think they're too fat
absolutely not
I used to see a lot of these gals in the
70s and 80s when I practiced up in
Portland Oregon because that was the
time of Olga Corbett and you may
remember her as being the darling of the
world because
um
she'd want every gymnastic event in the
Olympics and same Olympia ad with a
perfect score and everybody wanted their
little girl to be an Olga Corbett and I
used to see them they'd get split lips
and fractured and dislocations because
they you know they weren't all perfect
and they'd hit those bars going full
speed and and get dislocations and split
lips and twists and sprains and strains
and bruises but the ones that fascinated
me were the little 8 10 12 years old
that were depressed and anorexic
certainly not typical of a teenage girl
or preteen girl and so I used to do hair
analysis on them because that was the
only way I could communicate with them
because they weren't sociable they
wouldn't eat they didn't want to study
or they didn't want to do their
Athletics anymore and sure enough every
one of them were severely deficient in
many many nutrients 30 40 nutrients but
all of them were uniformly severely
deficient in two trace minerals zinc and
lithium zinc and lithium so I began to
give them as many as 25 or 30 nutrients
intravenously two or three times a week
paying special attention to giving them
lots of zinc and lithium and sure enough
in 14 to 21 days they were eating like
little pigs again they were real
interested in going out and and training
they were sociable again
and all the parents who took their
little girls who were anorexic to
counselors and shrinks those little
girls were counseled unto death now you
may remember Karen Carpenter from the
singing group The brother sister the
Carpenters she was 30 years old to give
or take a year or so she developed
anorexia because they had lots of money
they went around the world and went to
all the shrinks and and the counselors
in Moscow and Berlin and London and
Paris all over the United States and
they counseled her unto death
because you cannot counsel somebody well
who has a terminal zinc deficiency you
have to give them some zinc
now what possibly could be the common
denominator between a 65 pound gymnast a
seven foot tall basketball player 250
pound box or heavyweight boxing champion
and these Runners that have less than
four percent body fat on them
what could possibly be the common
denominator
they all sweat
and when you sweat you sweat out all 60
essential nutrients all 60 essential
minerals you don't just sweat out you
don't just sweat out potassium and
Gatorade you sweat out all 60 essential
minerals
and when you sweat out all of your
selenium and don't replace it by
supplementation
on the average you're going to get a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you sweat
out all of your copper and don't replace
it by supplementation you're going to
get an aneurysm you sweat out all of
your chromium and Vanadium you're going
to get diabetes you sweat out all of
your gallium and don't replace it you're
going to get a brain cancer if you're a
teenage girl and you sweat out all of
your zinc in your lithium you're going
to get anorexia
get the picture now the reason why
athletes are early warning system as a
rule they sweat out more in 20 to 30
years and a couch potato dozen 80 years
they've compressed a whole lifetime of
sweating into 20 years that's why there
are early Warning Systems now you don't
have to be an athlete to sweat though
let's say you're postmenopausal woman
and you have night sweats let's say
you're a welder or a farmer a carpenter
let's say you work in the oven room of a
Pizza Hut any place that you sweat even
if you work in a an office situation
where you have an air-conditioned office
and you just use a keyboard and you
never get one bead of sweat on you I
mean you can go a whole week wear the
same clothes nobody will know right
but then you go out every night and you
do aerobics or you jog and you sweat
them so it doesn't matter why your sweat
weather is for recreation are at work if
you don't replace those minerals you're
in line you're putting yourself at high
high risk of developing a lot of these
degenerative diseases many of which are
debilitating and certainly many of which
are fatal
what's the very first symptom of mineral
deficiencies in animals and people it's
called Pica and cribbing Farmers know
about this when they see an animal
chewing on The Hitching Post and these
are a couple Amish horses up in
Lancaster County Pennsylvania when they
see them chewing on The Hitching Post
the fence rails things like shovel
handles the half doors on the barn the
door jams on the barn a good farmer
recognizes this as an animal that's in
trouble though they are minerally
deficient
how many of you either are or know of a
chocoholic raise your hand
yeah that's the munchies that's Pike and
cribbing that's a mineral deficiency
it's the only thing will cause that how
many of you know of a cocoholic or a
pepsiolic raise your hand yeah how a day
without 12 Pepsi's I can't function okay
these are minerally deficient people and
that's one of the reasons why we have a
weight challenge in America because
people have been taught to put calories
in their mouth instead of minerals
there's no calories and minerals next
time you have these terrible Cravings
instead of putting chips and dips and
chocolate and donuts in your mouth try
some minerals you'll not only lose
weight but you'll feel better and live
longer
foreign
mineral is lithium the reason why I like
lithium is shrinks think it's a drug
that only they can prescribe when in
fact is one of those 60 essential
minerals that everybody needs every day
and like all essential nutrients if it's
missing if it's missing for
um six months nine months 12 months a
year or so you get on the average 10
deficiency diseases which include
depression manic depression bipolar
disease suicidal Behavior violent
Behavior spouse abuse child abuse
domestic violence drug addictions
alcohol addictions these are all
symptoms of lithium deficiency and
people who've been challenged with sugar
natural or processed we'll talk more
about that in a minute I believe we
should be putting lithium in our
drinking water because first of all it's
safer than chlorine and fluorine and
number two we could eliminate 85 percent
of all domestic violence that we would
just put lithium in our drinking water
now you can pick up and diagnose a child
with lithium deficiency and one who's in
trouble by looking at their coloring
projects
if you look at their coloring projects
if they're deficient lithium and are
sensitive to Sugar we'll talk about that
in a second
these are kids who are going to take a
dark color black brown purple dark red
dark blue dark green and scribble all
over the page with little or no intent
to stay in the lines
these are kids who are in trouble
you can project these four or
five-year-olds are going to drop out of
high school they're not going to learn
how to write read or do math they're
going to have a lousy personal life
they're never going to be happy during a
marriage they're going to be violent
types and so forth these are kids who
are in trouble they're going to
experiment with cigarettes and alcohol
and drugs but they're salvageable
because this is the same kid here six
weeks later simply getting them off of
sugar natural and processed no apple
juice no grape juice no honey no
molasses no Pepsis no chocolate no Ding
Dongs no sugar Frosted Flakes and that
sort of thing and supplemented them this
kid with lithium chromium and Vanadium
look at the heels and the boots and the
boots the glove the uniform sleeve the
glove the border on the foot
and the border on the hat and so forth
all in the lines the tail and so on and
with more appropriate colors you can
save these kids if you just pay
attention it's not they don't just have
an art aptitude they're in trouble okay
now if these kids also
wet the bed far after they're supposed
to be potty trained they're six eight
ten twelve fourteen years old and they
wet the bed
they have a history of scribbling all
over the page without staying in the
lines they are cruel to little animals
and other kids and they love to play
with matches and fire these are kids who
if you don't save them at this early age
you can project they're going to become
mass murders and serial killers it just
happens that way
here's what happens next you start
getting kids with what's called
Geographic tongues Geographic tongues
are red pulpy and painful they have
ulcers and erosions all over their
tongues these kids have zero brain waves
they can't learn how to read write and
do math if you don't take care of them
there they're going to drop out of
school and experiment with cigarettes
alcohol and drugs when they hit 12 14 16
years old look at the allergic shiners
under this kid's eyes
this is not physical abuse he's just
sensitive to sugar and people are
sensitive to Sugar just like some people
are sensitive to alcohol you know
there's a good alcoholic if a person who
will drink a beer and a shot of whiskey
they'll go to sleep these are quote good
alcoholics there's people who drink a
beer maybe have a shot of whiskey and
they get boisterous and obnoxious and
they start singing loud songs and being
loud and they think jokes are funny that
aren't funny and then you get people who
drink and they just get mean and
become downright dangerous to themselves
and everybody else the same thing is
true as sugar there's some people who
take in sugar and they get low blood
sugar and they just go to sleep some
people who get taken sugar they get
Rowdy and attention deficit disorder
ADHD hyperactivity learning disabilities
and they get kind of obnoxious and then
there are people who take in sugar and
they become serial killers and they get
violent and so people are sensitive to
Sugar just like they are too alcohol
and you get them off of sugar National
and process and supplement them with
lithium chromium and Vanadium you can
save them and everybody around them
here's a 20 year old you don't need to
be a clinical psychologist to see that
he's depressed look at the allergic
shiners under his eyes and these are the
type of kids who live on Pepsis and Ding
Dongs their whole life they're quiet
they stay in their rooms they're with
their headsets they listen to their
music or they might play on the
keyboards or their computers and then
one day when grandma gives them an
irritation of about a 0.1 on the scale
of 1 to 10 you got to do the dishes
before I give you the car keys they'll
walk into the kitchen pick up the
Cleaver and smack Grandma's head off
they'll respond with a 10 right and
they're just irritated 0.1 now this is
all too common right now experts say
that 30 of All American teenagers are
going to appear in juvenile court in
1996 one-third of All American teenagers
a terrible tragedy but these things do
go on all the time and uh back I guess
it was the third week in in January of
this year 1996
I was at Moses Lake Washington on a
Monday night actually giving a seminar
like this and when it got to this point
guys in the front row said doc you don't
have to talk about teen violence in
Moses Lake I mean there's more people in
this National Guard Armory than there is
in the whole town and we only have a
couple hundred teenagers and they all
know each other by first name it's kind
of like a big family and they didn't
believe they had any teen problems in
Moses Lake well that was Monday night
Friday at two in the afternoon an honor
student in junior high school walks in
with his deer rifle blows away the math
teacher and two of his fellow students
now this kid was not on drugs he was not
a member of any gang there's no drugs
and gangs in Moses Lake Washington you
know the answer to why this happened I'm
going to bring it out of you
what time of the year is there more
domestic violence depression and suicide
than any other time of year
Christmas holidays a week before
Christmas Christmas the time between
Christmas and New Year's from New Year's
until now Super Bowl day in fact Super
Bowl day has the largest number of
violent incidents in any other day of
the year Super Bowl day
what happens during these holidays that
happens more than any other time of year
sugar I heard people say a sugar you get
more cake more pie more candy more
cookies more punch more colas and drinks
of various kinds than you get any other
time of year it's not just on Sunday
afternoon I mean we're talking four
times a day in school after school in
the evening four times or ten times on
the weekend because it's party time
during the holidays and as a result the
people who are sensitive to sugar and
are going to get violent are depressed
come out during this time
especially if they're deficient in
lithium chromium and vanadium
pension deficit disorder another one of
those physician caused diseases because
Physicians say sugar is okay it's better
to have Ritalin than sugar
you can have both you know if you're
good you can have sugar and Ritalin well
if you take someone who has ADD or ADHD
tension deficit disorder attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder
regardless of age whether they're two or
six or eight or fifteen or twenty five
or forty
and take them off of all sugar natural
and process and supplement them with all
90 nutrients paying special attention to
make sure that they get lithium chromium
and Vanadium 98 I can't use the Cure
word but 98 will get 100 better
now the whole family has to do the same
thing you can't be guzzling Cokes and
eating donuts and expect a six-year-old
or 18 year old to give it up the whole
family has to change and eat the same
way for the benefit not only of that
child but for the whole family because
if something goes wrong the whole family
is in trouble
now this little gal here 300 years ago
would have been a vampire or a werewolf
your own villagers would have burned her
to death at the stake maybe the village
Elders would have killed her by driving
a wooden stake through her heart you may
remember her as Susan Smith the mother
who drowned her two sons from Union
South Carolina
and we learned a lot about her during
her trial number one she tried to commit
suicide twice during High School
a lithium and chromium deficiency nobody
said to her Susan give up all sugar
National process we're going to give you
some lithium chromium and vanadium
they didn't even give her any Prozac all
they did was give her a hug and say
Susan everybody loves you and if you get
depressed again let everybody know and
we'll talk you out of this suicide thing
two years after graduating high school
she went further into her depression
they diagnosed her as being a manic
depressant they put her on Prozac at
that time nobody took her off of sugar
and supplemented her with any lithium
chromium and Vanadium and two years
later when her boyfriend realized how
wacky she was at that time tried to
disengage and break off from her and he
used the kids as a foil purposely
because most single mothers when put to
the test you have to give up your kids
if you want me to stay with you because
you know I'm not big enough to handle
these kids every time I look at those
kids I see another man
he says you got to give up those kids
and most women would say well you're out
of here you bum I'm not going to give up
my kids if you don't take the package
deal you don't get anything
but she didn't do that the night before
she drowned those two boys she went from
telephone to telephone pay telephone to
pay telephone in the parking lot so the
7-Elevens in Union South Carolina and
he tried to call this guy because she
figured out a way to make everybody
happy she remembered a little incident
that happened to her when she was six
years old
and it goes like this
when she was six years old she had six
kittens and she wanted to keep them all
she loved them all but her daddy said
hey we can only afford to take care of
two so you got to give up four and he
took four of them out of her arms and
put him into a sack with a brick and
tied the sack and threw him into a pond
and drowned him he said now that was
painless didn't hurt those kittens and
they're happy because they're in heaven
with God and God's happy because those
kittens are with him and you're happy
because you get to keep two instead of
none and I'm happy because I don't have
to feed six I only have to feed two
she remembered that story and she said
well I can make everybody happy here
I'll just drown those two boys and it'll
be painless and they'll be happy because
they'll be in heaven with God and God
will be happy because they're in heaven
with them and I'll be happy because I
get my boyfriend and he'll be happy
because he gets me without the kids
nobody took her off of any sugar
National process or supplemented her
with any lithium chromium or vanadium
one more tragic story here and then
we'll get into the summary slides and
then we'll open up for questions see if
there's any health challenges you want
to talk about
this kid here I could have picked out
from his coloring projects when he was
four years old guaranteed we call him
the Willy Wonka serial killer how many
of you have ever seen the movie Willy
Wonka and the and the Chocolate Factory
raise your hand yeah pretty fun little
movie
we call him a Willy Wonka serial killer
when he was four years old he was caught
on this on the shoulder of a little
State Highway in Indiana HH eating Road
kills like hard taco shells I mean we
used to call these things sale cats they
were run over so many times they're dry
you could use them like frisbees right
talk about Pica and cribbing I mean he
was eating roadkills at age four
when he was seven years old he was
thought to be part of a satanic cult
because he was twisting the heads off
his neighbors chickens and nailing them
to the door jambs cutting the heads off
their dogs and cats putting them on
Pikes and planting them in front of
their yard cruelty to little animals he
wet the bed until he was 12 years old
when he was 13 years old
he was a full-blown alcoholic he'd sit
in class and drink beer cans and crunch
them and disrupt the class but his
teachers were terrified to kick him out
of class because he threatened to burn
their house down he loved to play with
fire
all right now because he was such a
threatening kid they gave him straight
A's and graduated him a year early out
of high school
moved him right along he then joined the
army and became a medic because he had
such good grades they made him a medic
and encouraged him to apply to medical
school the only reason he did not get
into medical school was he was being
treated as an alcoholic in the Army he
said hey you dry out I've applied to
medical school again we'll take you
well after three years the Army kicked
him out as being a hopeless alcoholic he
moved up to Milwaukee he lived with his
grandmother and he worked in a chocolate
factory for four years and he ate
chocolate for breakfast lunch and supper
because it was free to employees and
used his minimum wage paycheck to buy
alcohol and drugs at night
and in four years when that chocolate
didn't hold this horrible craving he had
anymore he killed his member in eight
parts of 17 human beings
Jeffrey Dahmer
nobody's told him anywhere along his
life to give up sugar and supplement
with lithium chromium and Vanadium all
he did was say now Jeffrey it's not nice
to kill this member and eat people
we require 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 6-0 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and fortunately
for the thousands of years we've been
around we haven't had to think about
this too much as human beings because
our food plants our grains fruits
vegetables and us take carbon dioxide
from the air and manufacture long carbon
chains long carbon chains and many of
these long carbon chains or vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids
and this is where this myth came from
you can get everything you need from
your four food groups because plants do
manufacture a certain amount of vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids but we've
tried this experiment for
hundred years or 200 years and we've
learned if you eat the four food groups
and don't supplement
you can live to be an average of 75.5
about half of what we're genetically
capable of
so I sat down one day and I said well
how much of these grains fruits and
vegetables and nuts you have to eat
every day to live to be over a hundred
and I calculate you need six cups each
of 15 different plant groups
grains fruits vegetables and nuts to get
enough vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids to live to be over 100. that's 90
cups a day
it's a full bushel now you have two
problems if you want to do that number
one you have a capacity problem if
anybody in this room can eat a bushel of
anything I'll give you a hundred dollar
bill
number two if you eat a bushel of fruits
and vegetables every day guess where
you're going to spend most of your life
you guessed it you're gonna be on that
little house pot you know going through
about 10 rolls of Charmin a day
you'll only be able to work with a
laptop computer and a cellular telephone
because you're not going to go
not gonna be able to go anywhere else
so even though it is directly possible
to get all the vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids you need from eating your
four food groups you can only expect to
get 75.5 give or take sometimes 80 years
sometimes 65 years but on the average
75.5 if you want to live to be over 100
and be helpful you have to take in
supplements of vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids now minerals are a different
story plants cannot manufacture minerals
the only minerals that you find in
plants are those that are in the soil in
which they're grown plants will take up
minerals out of the soil and the reason
why we're in trouble in America is for
the last hundred years we've used a
simple fertilizer NPK nitrogen
phosphorus potassium we did on our farm
people still do today and they will for
the next Thousand Years use the simple
fertilizer NPK because it gives the
farmer the maximum yield in terms of
tons and bushels per acre farmers are
paid for tons and bushels nobody gives a
farmer any type of tax incentive or cash
incentive to make sure that you get all
60 essential minerals
that's your responsibility Farmers Only
generate tons and bushels per acre
that's what they do and they do a very
good job we know that only takes five to
ten years to deplete the nutritional
minerals out of our farm soils and we've
been using NPK for 100 years so you know
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to figure out that there's a deficit
there U.S Senate document 264 says
there's no longer any nutritional
minerals left in our farm and Rain soils
and as a result the crops that are grown
there are minimally deficient as a
result the animals and people who eat
these minimally deficient crops get
mineral deficiency diseases and the only
way to prevent and cure them is with
mineral supplementation as U.S Senate
document 264.
now to me the scary thing about U.S
Senate document 264 is that it was
written and published by the U.S Senate
in 1936 60 years ago this information
was known 60 years ago
this is not yesterday's news it's 60
years old this is the time at which we
began to put vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals into animal feeds to make
up the deficit unfortunately
unfortunately for human beings we got
Wonder drugs at the same time we got
sulfa drugs in 1936 we got penicillin
and 38 Cortisone and 42 and everybody
was led to believe it we give medical
research enough money in enough time
they'll find a one or drug to fix
everything you just need to eat your
four food groups and run around
willy-nilly and everything will be all
right one of the studies of fascinating
to me in Rio in 1992 at the Earth Summit
was this study here where they compared
the amount of minerals in our farm and
Rain cells compared to what was in there
100 years ago
African Farm cells are 74 depleted Asian
Farm cells are 76 depleted European Farm
cells are 72 percent depleted South
America 76 percent the United States and
Canada North America is 85 percent
depleted
where 10 to 15 percent worse off than
anybody else and of course the reason is
we had the Marshall Plan after the
second world war for 40 years we fed the
world more tons and bushels they thought
humanly possible to grow
per acre and all we put back in the saw
was NPK NPK then there were 16 years of
the Russian wheat deals and I put back
in the soil was NPK NPK that's why our
soils are depleted
now if I haven't gotten your attention
yet
I want to show you this map this is an
overlay map of the continental United
States that black areas have absolutely
no selenium in it and the dark gray
areas it's so irregular that you
wouldn't want to bet your life on what
may or may not be in there
so if you go to to a farmer's market on
the weekend or you have your own garden
what's the chances of you having enough
selenium in your food to live to be 100
without supplementation zero
every farmer knows about this and they
put it in their animal feeds
if you think animals just need it and
not people
okay let's look at two minerals before
we wind it up
let's look at calcium the number one
mineral in the body your body contains
more calcium than any other mineral
147 different diseases if you're
deficient in calcium I'm just going to
go over the top 10 with you osteoporosis
everybody knows about that today it's
the number 10 killer of adults over the
age of 65. remember 75 don't live 90
days you get complications from those
fractures
it's a horrible disease in terms of
human misery and dollars spent thirty
five thousand dollars to have a hip
replaced get them both replaces seventy
thousand dollars
if that's uncomplicated if it's
complicated and have all kinds of
problems it might be a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand dollars
now as a terrible disease as
osteoporosis is in human beings we don't
have osteoporosis and animals that's
because Farmers have a lot of common
sense
let's say a farmer out here has a
hundred head of cattle on his pasture
and no calves this year calls the vet
out and he says hey Doc I'm in trouble I
haven't had any cabs this year can't
repay the operating loan I lost a lot of
money he says do I get rid of this herd
and that'll come out and examine the
cows he says no the cows are all okay
but that bull up and that shed up there
has osteoporosis of both hips had so
much pain couldn't breed the cows that's
why I don't have any calves
he says as a result
as a result he said
what I want you to do is give me seventy
thousand dollars I give that bull two
new hips and next year you'll have some
calves
now a farmer being very practical is
saying now stand over here Doc and he
whips out his deer rifle boom blows away
the bull and while the kids are cutting
the bull up in the hamburger and roast
and steaks the pharmacy now dock for
seventy thousand dollars I can get a new
bull every year for 70 years so I'm
going to spend that kind of money in
that old Bowl but every once in a while
we get one we'd like to keep because he
throws good camps can we prevent this
osteoporosis thing and that'll say well
sure you want to prevent it all you got
to do is take 10 cents every day and the
pellets worth of calcium 10 cents worth
of calcium every day and the pellets of
those calves when you wean them off the
cow
and you won't get osteoporosis and the
farmer says wait a minute we can prevent
a seventy thousand to a hundred thousand
dollar vet bill simply with 10 cents a
day worth of calcium he says yep the
farmer says well since I don't have Blue
Cross Blue Shield major medical
hospitalization Medicare medicator
Hillary to watch out for those calves I
got to pay for this out of my own pocket
he said I'm going to do the 10 cent a
day calcium thing that's why we don't
have osteoporosis in animals receding
gums dentists and dental hygienists will
tell you to floss and brush and for
every meal if you believe that receding
gums can be prevented or cured by
flossing and brushing I have some ocean
front property in Idaho I'd like to sell
you because you're an easy sell
now as a veterinarian I've literally
seen hundreds of thousands of animals
rats mice rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs
horses cows lions and tigers and bears
and they don't floss them they don't get
receding gums now they do get funky
breath
because they don't floss but they don't
get receding gums now the reason why we
don't get receding gums in animals is
because we've dealt with the
osteoporosis thing if you have receding
gums regardless of your age whether
you're 12 15 20 25 30 40 50 60 70 80 it
doesn't matter if you have receding gums
loose teeth gingivitis pyorrhea
periodontitis Bridges or plates you have
osteoporosis of the face or jaw bones
you see this 20 to 50 years before you
can recognize osteoporosis and the large
bones of your arms legs hips pelvis and
vertebrae
so if you have any of these problems you
have osteoporosis of the face and jaw
bones arthritis
85 of all arthritis is wear and tear
arthritis 85 percent of all arthritis is
wear and tear arthritis osteoarthritis
degenerative arthritis Ankylosing
Spondylitis and of course
um
this is the type of arthritis that can
be prevented and you might get 100
better if you use Dr wallach's bigger
arthritis formula which is made up out
of a liquid multiple made up out of a
liquid multiple a plant derived
that has 72 colloidal minerals in it
we'll talk about colloidal minerals in
just a second and a liquid multiple and
the gelatin we talked about either Knox
or Willamette Valley gelatin either a
half ounce or the the 12 capsules and
five ounces of the calcium enrichment
made orange juice all that together
makes up Dr wallach's Pig arthritis
formula and taken Faithfully twice a day
you have every honest expectation of
getting significantly better or maybe
even 100 better even if your neck sounds
like a bag full of gravel your joints
sound like you have Rice Krispies in
there you know snap crackle and pop you
can't get up on a chair yourself you
have excruciating pain and so on you
want to give it a try if you have wear
and tear arthritis
hypertension again we've already talked
about this hypertension has nothing to
do with salt intake salt restriction is
not going to prevent it or fix it
hypertension high blood pressure is
actually do 85 percent of all
hypertension is due to a Calcium
deficiency taken three times the RDA
recommended daily allowance by your
government and according to the inner
salt study and the study from Toronto
Medical School the calcium will resolve
your high blood pressure
insomnia as you roll around all night
wake up in the morning more tired when
you went to bed contrary to popular
belief by physicians is not due to a
barbiturate deficiency or an ins are a
Halcyon deficiency is due to a Calcium
deficiency kidney stones bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits the medical
profession has the malignant dumb belief
that these things are due to too much
calcium in your diet and the first
advice they give you when you have any
of these problems give up all Dairy and
for God's sake don't take any
supplements with calcium in them when in
fact when you get kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
you have raging osteoporosis it's your
own calcium being moved around you need
more calcium more magnesium not less I
want you to be honest with me how many
of you ever had a
foot cramped toe cramp leg cramp eyelid
twitch or anything like that in your
life raise your hand yeah that's the
first symptom of a Calcium deficiency if
you're honest you'll you'll fess up to
that myself when I was a kid when I was
a teenager my eyelids used to Twitch so
violently you could hear them click I
used to look into the into the mirror
and say do people see that is that my
imagination and one day I got the
twitching and the clicking together and
I called my mom and she came in she
didn't know what it was so she panicked
we jumped in the car and we drove 80
miles to St Louis and I ran into my
first female doctor when I was 14 years
old
now remember she's an eye doctor her
name was Mary Jane skeffington
Mary Jane skeffington the eye doctor for
some reason I'm 14 years old she had me
stripped down to my Jockey underwear
now back then I was just a dumb redneck
kid from the farm and I didn't know any
better whatever she said I did now today
if a eye doctor were to do that you
could go on Geraldo or Oprah and say you
were sexually harassed by your eye
doctor right
but anyway she kept looking in my eye
with this ophthalmoscope for an hour and
then go see another patient she'd look
into my eye without the scope and see
another patient he went on and on and on
for two hours and finally said doc you
know listen I played junior varsity
football I'm a captain of the wrestling
team I actually
um I'm on the weightlifting team and if
you have to amputate my eyelids go for
it I can handle whatever you need to do
so she goes into her office she comes
back she has a little Maybelline mascara
eyelash brush a little mirror and one of
those little plastic boxes and I said
what's that far she says well the
structure of your eye seems to be okay
but you have these real long eyelashes
they've grown forward hit your
eyeglasses they've curled bangers
tickling your eyeball that's what's
causing your eyelids to Twitch
I said you're kidding me she says no
that appears to be what it is and I said
well well what do we do about it and she
says well what I want you to do is every
hour I want you to alternate eyes take
15 minutes uh in each hour and work and
retrain those eyelashes and she starts
demonstrating to me you know you got to
do it like this
I said wait a minute let's get this
straight
we're going to sit on the football bench
with 25 guys
weighing over 200 pounds this is a 1950
right
and you want me to sit there with a
Maybelline mascara eyelash brush and
play with my eyelashes
and not only does my team have cleats on
their feet there's these guys across the
field 25 guys over 200 pounds
I said you got to be crazy so I put on
my pants I said she doesn't know
anything about football right so I I
went marching to the school library and
I found a health book out of desperation
that was written by two nurses and I
looked in the index and said muscle
cramps muscle twitches I looked in the
book where it said to look and sure
enough
it said this is all due to a Calcium
deficiency and I said I know how to
solve this problem I know we have some
calcium it's in the calf pellets in the
barn so I ran to the barn I started
filling all my pockets and my pants and
my shirt and my jacket with calf pellets
and the next day at school everybody
else is eating M M's and jelly beans old
Wallach is eating calf pellets because
the alternative was the Maybelline
mascara eyelash treatment
so I was motivated
now in four to five days all those
cramps and Twitches went away
all those cramps and Twitches went away
so when I was 14 years old I knew that
doctors didn't know anything about
nutrition and that eye doctors perhaps
should go back to school and learn some
Anatomy because they didn't know where
the eyes were
PMS premenstrual syndrome the University
of California San Diego came out six
years ago and said that 85 percent of
the emotional and physical stuff a PMs
can be relieved prevented and cured
they're using the Cure word not me by
tripling your intake of calcium over and
above the RDA
now low back pain
that's a pretty common thing low back
pain how many of you either yourself or
have known somebody that had a disc
surgery for back pain and still had pain
or more pain after the surgery raise
your hand
isn't that amazing almost 40 50 of the
people in the room
now Harvard Medical School is getting
the same feedback and they said there's
something wrong with this picture we're
doing these heroic disc surgeries to
relieve pain and 50 of the people are
still having pain
so they looked at it and they said okay
here's what we're going to do they took
1700 people who had no history of back
problems never never had a back problem
and they were in the teaching hospital
at Harvard for our say cataract
operations 1700 of them they did CAT
scans on their back
85 of those 1700 people had bulging
degenerative and ruptured disc
and Harvard Medical School eight months
ago came out and said if anybody gets a
disc operation for back pain it's
medical fraud because disc problems do
not cause back pain
disc problems can cause tingling
numbness and paralysis but not back pain
when you have low back pain you have
cramps and spasms or large muscles of
your back you can have subluxations or
male alignments or the vertebrae you
have bone spurs calcium deposits
arthritis osteoporosis but not disc
problems
if you have any of these top 10 problems
I'm going to try Dr wallach's bigger
arthritis formula before you you know
like to have any surgery don't be like
the average American who spends between
000 and 250 000 and undergoes five to
ten surgical procedures for nothing more
than the top 10 Calcium deficiency
diseases in America it's really a
terrifying thing that people can be
talked into that
okay last disease one more slide after
this diabetes the number three killer of
adults the United States causes
blindness of all kinds kidney failure
kidney dialysis kidney transplant
contributes to the numbers of
cardiovascular disease the number one
killer of animals in the United States
amputations of toes feet and legs for
ulcers that won't heal and gangrene and
most times you really don't have to get
an amputation to resolve those problems
but if you insist on getting something
amputated please please put a tag on it
so they get the right one
you know if you guys go in for an
inguinal surgery operation you want to
get a do not remove sign and put it in
the appropriate place
that happens
okay now
when your doctor diagnoses a new
diabetic patient in his office he
excuses himself goes into his private
office drops to his knees and gives
thanks to the Lord then he jumps up and
he calls his real estate agent because
he knows over 20 30 40 years you're
going to go through all these problems
if you follow the standard treatment or
management of diabetes and human
medicine and as a result over 20 30 40
years your Worth to him 250 000 to 500
000 is like adding another cow to the
dairy herd they know exactly how much
you're worth to them as a diabetic
and if you don't think that's true next
time you visit a doctor ask to see his
medical business office journals you
know they have business journals for
doctors and see what they say about
diabetic patients and heart patients and
cancer patients and how much on the
average that's why people pick certain
Specialties because there's big bucks in
that area now to me this is Criminal
because in 1957 we learned that we could
prevent and cure adult onset diabetes
and animals by supplementing with two
trace minerals chromium and Vanadium
chromium and vanadium
and 11 years ago 1985 the medical school
up at British Columbia Vancouver Canada
came out and said that the trace mineral
Vanadium alone could replace insulin for
adult onset diabetics so again make up
85 percent of the diabetic population
besides that dog food contains 40
minerals in a complete analysis always
contains lithium chromium Vanadium and
selenium
Ralston Purina laboratory rat pellets
always contains a minimum of 28 minerals
and they always contain lithium chromium
Vanadium and selenium and I'll give
anybody in this audience a crisp new
hundred dollar bill if you can find the
human infant formula contains more than
12 minerals
none of them contain lithium chromium
Vanadium and only one pro soybean the
one has 12 has selenium in it none the
rest do they have 11 10 9 or 8 minerals
that's why they call Similac Similac
because it lacks everything
now if I've convinced you that minerals
and nutrition are important to
preventing disease and adding Health and
Longevity to your life you have to be
responsible for this because your doctor
doesn't get 30 seconds worth of clinical
nutrition in their medical school as a
result this is a blind spot for them and
something they never consider when a
person comes in with a Health Challenge
they never consider this aspect of the
disease
now you have to know three things about
minerals number one there's three types
of mineral supplements there's the
original going back since time
immemorial since the beginning of time
there's Elemental or metallic minerals
these are things like Limestone oyster
shell eggshell seabed minerals Coral
Calcium things like um oh Clays of
various types Tums is a modern version
of it eight to twelve percent
availability to animals and people were
not designed to consume ground up rocks
if you will to get our minerals have you
ever wondered why people dread being 50
years old why the whole population of
the world suddenly falls apart when they
hit 50 you know the teeth get loose the
hair goes whatever you got left is gray
low back problems high blood pressure
sugar in your urine interest in sex goes
away everybody dreads the big 5-0 right
well the reason is
our ability to absorb these Elemental
types of minerals precipitously drops to
three to five percent
about three years ago a guy in Grand
Rapids Michigan jumps up in the back of
the room says hey Doc now I know what I
see in my porta potty business I said
what do you see in your porta potty
business he's well when we clean those
things out and disinfect them so we can
use them again we find hundreds and
hundreds of vitamin pills that come
through people say come on now how do
you know their vitamin pills is well
that's easy they say their gram M One A
Day Centrum and Centrum Silver right on
the coating
so next time you're on the pot and you
hear a plop plop clink clink it's not
poker chips coming through there
it's in pills
are there any chiropractors in the
audience tonight any chiropractors any
chiropractors raise your hand so you can
see
I can't see any huh okay well the reason
why I asked that is because
chiropractors take spinal x-rays
and when a chiropractor takes his final
x-ray guess what he sees he sees all
these pills lined up and if a person
tends to be constipated those pills line
up like little box cars waiting to come
out
a lot of people say to me Doc
listen you know are you kind of fibbing
to us a little bit here pulling our leg
I mean I've taken 2 000 milligrams of
calcium every day for 20 years I take a
thousand milligram two of those thousand
milligram tablets every day for 20 years
and I still have insomnia foot cramps
toe cramps high blood pressure bone
spurs heel spurs arthritis loose teeth
my neck sounds like a bag full of gravel
and I say what kind do you take and
they'll say calcium carbonate calcium
gluconate calcium lactate and that's the
problem
because out of a thousand milligram
calcium lactate tablet
86 or 860 milligrams is lactose or milk
sugar only 14 or 140 milligrams is
Elemental or metallic calcium and let's
not use these complicated numbers up
here for absorption and usability let's
take 10 percent
of the um 140 milligrams it's a honest
number and also it's easy math 10 of 140
milligrams is 14 milligrams so if you
take two of those thousand milligram
tablets a day of calcium lactate or
calcium carbonate or calcium gluconate
you're not getting 2 000 milligrams of
calcium you're getting 2 times 14 are 28
milligrams to get enough to get enough
calcium to get 2 000 milligrams of
usable calcium from a calcium lactate
thousand milligram tablet you have to
take 30 of those with each meal if take
90 a day that's almost a full 100 tablet
bottle and the cheapest the five you
know five bucks a bottle it's 150 bucks
a month just for calcium you got 59 more
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids to
go so this is not a an efficient way
financially to take in minerals because
you've got all these other nutrients to
deal with plus you got the plop plop
ding ding Factor you know
and additionally you're going to develop
a another physician cause disease if
they tell you to take this type of
calcium you're going to develop what I
call BNF disease BNF disease stands for
belching and farting
if you take in a 90 capsules of anything
a day you're going to develop BNF
disease you're going to sound like an
elephant out in the woods with a
horrible belly problem
and you know you got it when your spouse
has to throw a canary in the bathroom to
see if it's safe to go in there
foreign
[Applause]
the 60s the animal industry came up with
chelated minerals because no farmer is
dumb enough to put a dollar in an
animal's mouth and have 99 Cents come
out in the manure so we learned by
adding amino acids and proteins and
enzymes which are proteins that do work
to the elemental mineral it increases
the absorbability from three to five
percent to 40 percent and everybody got
excited about this during the 60s and
today because of this research you'll
see a mixture of Elemental minerals and
chelated minerals in a good multivitamin
mineral supplement you know a tablet
but the way that animals and people are
designed to consume and absorb minerals
is in the colloidal form colloidal
minerals are 98 available to animals and
people two and a half times more
available than the chelated minerals 10
times more available than Elemental or
metallic
they're liquid in farm by definition
they cannot be powders and capsules and
pills and tablets they must be liquid
small particle size There's 7 000 times
smaller than a red blood cell and
they're negatively charged as one of the
unique things about a colloidal mineral
is they are all negatively charged and
as you know like charges repel so
between being a small particle and they
repel each other they stay in suspension
forever as long as you don't let the
water evaporate now the way it's
supposed to be is that
animals and human beings are supposed to
eat plants and the plants are supposed
to take the elemental minerals out of
the soil convert them to colloidal
minerals for their own use for their own
metabolism and biochemistry we eat the
plants and that's how animals and people
are designed to consume and absorb
minerals in the Plant Farm colloidal
minerals we are not designed to eat
ground up rocks
unfortunately U.S Senate document 264
1936 says there's no more minerals left
in our farm and Rain cells unfortunately
in 1992 there are some in Rio says
there's no more minerals left in our
farm and Rain cells and plants cannot
manufacture minerals if there's no
minerals in the soil they cannot make
they cannot convert these minerals to
colloidal minerals and they cannot
manufacture minerals now what about
these long-lived cultures that were
written up in the National Geographic in
January of 1973. what was special about
them is it genetic no they're all
different races they're all different
religions different cultures
the Tibetans from certain Mountain
tribes up there in the Himalayas and the
hunzas and the Eastern Pakistan the
caracurum mountains the Russian
Georgians azerbaijanis abkhasians and
the turkistanis in the Caucasus
Mountains in Western Russia and the
vilcabamba Indians
from the Andes of Ecuador and my
favorites I just like the name the
titicacas and the Andes of Peru
what could possibly be a common
denominator between all these peoples
well there are two number one even
though they're different religions in
different races they were all persecuted
people they're all victims being chased
by the kings men or Bandits or whatever
and they chose to live in what would be
called the Badlands of their country I
mean horrible nothing no soil nothing
but Rock
and just out of the throw of the dice
nothing that they thought about they
picked places to live in that had 60 to
72 minerals in the parent rock of the
mountains they chose to live in number
two they chose places that had less than
two inches of precipitation a year no
rain no snow to speak of so they had to
pick places they had a permanent water
supply and every one of these cultures
picked places that were within 50 to 100
miles of glaciers and they all built
aqueducts to carry water from glaciers
to their place where they lived and
worked and farmed
now the water that comes out from
underneath of glaciers is not clear like
tap water Perrier Evian or glacier water
or geyser water or Calistoga water it's
called glacial milk because the water
that comes out from underneath the
glaciers has so much rock dust or Rock
flour suspended in it that um
it's called glacial milk it looks like
whole milk kind of a bluish white bluish
gray as opposed to clear and if you boil
away a quart of glacial milk you get two
inches of minerals in the bottom of that
quart jug
by contrast boil away a quart of Evian
or Perrier water of 20 bucks a gallon
I mean we're talking price here compared
to gasoline would you ever have thought
that water would be more expensive than
gasoline
kind of interesting isn't it now you
boil away a quart of Evian or Perrier
water you'll get as much mineral as you
get on the head of a pin
a big contrast now not only do these
people drink this highly mineralized
water and get eight to twelve percent
and three to five percent after age 50
because it's metallic minerals it's
ground up rocks as these glaciers move
up and down the mountains more important
than drinking it
they irrigated with it week after week
month after month year after year
generation after generation for 2500 to
5 000 years they irrigated with this
glacial milk they replaced literally
thousands of tons of these minerals back
into the soil every year
through this irrigation with this
glacial milk and all their plants are
rich with these colloidal minerals as a
result
and all we do is put in NPK NPK NPK and
takes five to ten years to deplete these
nutritional minerals from our soil as a
result last year we paid 1.2 trillion
dollars that's with a t 1.2 trillion
dollars for health care
these people don't get diabetes they
don't get heart disease osteoporosis
arthritis cancer they don't get glaucoma
they don't get cataracts they don't have
birth defects they don't have jails full
of violent criminals and drug addicts
they don't have a single hospital they
don't have Blue Cross Blue Shield major
medical hospitalization they don't have
a single doctor and they don't have
these diseases and they live to be over
120 to 140.
now can you live to be over 120 140
without colloidal minerals no
can you get all these colloidal minerals
out of our food supply in the United
States no
well can you keep all the things that we
love about the United States because if
I were to pay your way to go there and
live and guarantee and live to be over
100 you wouldn't do it because they
don't have Kenmore kitchens they don't
have electricity they don't have central
heat central air they don't have roads
they don't have cars they don't have
televisions they don't have television
channel changes I mean how can you be a
couch potato without a television
channel changer
so can you have all these things we love
about America you know including health
insurance
and and still get colloidal minerals and
the answer is of course yes
these colloidal minerals are available
to you they've been around since 1926
and of course they're plant derived they
actually come from an ancient
prehistoric plant deposit
about 1926 there was this this
prospector who's an abysmal failure in
Southeastern Utah who noticed when he
even though he couldn't find gold or
silver but he did notice when he drank
this funky tasting water in the Stream
the only water source available to him
after a couple of weeks his arthritis
went away and he backtracked this stream
and he found that it originated in a
prehistoric Valley that had a forest in
it and when these trees and brush and
grasses took up all the elemental
minerals from the soil converted them to
colloidal minerals for their own use
there was a cataclysmic event that
forest was entombed that Valley in that
forest was entombed by a volcanic
eruption a very thin layer of mud Ashen
lava not heavy enough to compress this
stuff into coal or oil
it was very aired in there not enough
moisture to fossilize or petrify this
plant material so today if you look at
it it just looks like real dark
chocolate coffee grounds you squeeze it
between your fingers
you squeeze it between your fingers it
is the same consistency as a chocolate
chip you might put in an oatmeal cookie
it's kind of waxy
that's because it's not rock it's ground
up plant material we grind this stuff up
into a flower we soak it in a filtered
spring water for four to six weeks and
we Leach those colloidal minerals out of
those plants were taken up in the
prehistoric days things that you can't
get out of your soil and your food
anymore today
and of course has been around since 1926
we have liquid multiples that have been
around
oh 10 years and one year and so forth
and these are all available to you also
I want to thank you all very much God
bless each and every one of you and God
bless America
[Applause]
it shocks most people when they learn
that we need 90 essential nutrients we
need 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids it's even a bigger
shock to most people when they learn
that man's best friend the dog puts
farty minerals in his food are
laboratory rats get 28 minerals or less
on his food and the human infant their
Farm really gets 12 or less our dogs get
40 minerals our rats get 28 and their
own kids get 12 or less it's really a
dog's life
it's these minerals it's the secret
glaciers grind up these rocks comes out
in the form of glacial milk and these
people have irrigated with this glacial
milk
season after season year after year
generation after generation to 2500 to 5
000 years depending on the culture the
secret lies and the minerals that come
from these glaciers and these mountains
the U.S Senate document 264 says that
our farm and Rain soils are depleted in
minerals and as a result these crops are
deficient in minerals as a result of
that animals and people who eat on these
crops get mineral deficiency diseases
and one considers the budget that the
American family puts into their food
each month and the fact that U.S Senate
document 264 says there's no longer any
nutrients left in our farm soils and
their Foreigner Foods it's not
outrageous to think of making sure that
through a couple of dollars a day you
get all 90 essential nutrients it's kind
of like the modern version of an apple a
day keeps the doctor away
if you really want to find out what
health is like don't wait for the
government don't wait for insurance
don't wait for Medicare and Medicaid to
do it they're not going to do it for you
they can't do it for you even if they
wanted to take them full of your own
health do it today don't wait
[Music]
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you for more presentations
and books that go into greater detail go
to docwallikmedia.com and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the FDA these products are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease
the opinions expressed in this
informational program are the express
opinions of Joel D Wallach bsdvm ND are
not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment
in all cases we recommend you contact
your physician directly regarding any
medical conditions